Shop Best Buy's Ultimate Smartphone Sale today. Get a Best Buy gift card of up to $200 on select phone activations with major carriers. Visit your nearest Best Buy store today. Terms and conditions apply. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends.
选购百思买的终极智能手机促销活动。在指定主流运营商激活手机，即可获得高达200美元的百思买礼品卡。今天就光临离您最近的百思买门店。适用相关条款与条件。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。
And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hello. Hi there.
现在我们正在为你制作独家办公室重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。你好。嗨。
It's nice to be back after kind of a long break. Our biggest break we've ever taken. Yes, thanks for coming back with us, you guys. We're back with The Farm. It is season nine, episode 18, written by Paul Lieberstein and directed by Paul Lieberstein. But before we start breaking down The Farm, we have to make some Office Ladies announcements. In fact, all of our fast facts today are office ladies news. That's how much there is to tell you
在经历了相当长的一段时间休息后，很高兴能回来。这是我们有史以来最长的一次休息。是的，谢谢你们和我们一起回来。我们带着《农场》回来了。这是第九季第18集，由保罗·利伯斯坦编剧并导演。但在我们开始剖析《农场》之前，我们必须发布一些办公室女士的公告。事实上，我们今天所有的快速事实都是办公室女士的新闻。有那么多事情要告诉你
coming back from this break. Oh my goodness. I titled two of our announcements. Of course. You're like, of course, Angela, you would do that. The first one I'm calling a whopper. OK. It's a whopper announcement.
在经历了这次休息之后。哦天哪。我为我们的两个公告起了标题。当然。你会觉得，当然啦，安吉拉，你肯定会这么做。我把第一个称为超级大新闻。好的。这是一个超级大新闻。
I don't know if that's an expression, but guess what? Jenna, let's say it at the same time. Okay. One, two, three. We have a new podcasting partner! That's right! The Office Ladies Network is now going to be released by Odyssey. We are so excited about this new partnership.
我不知道这算不算一个表达，但你猜怎么着？珍娜，我们同时说出来。好的。一，二，三。我们有了一个新的播客合作伙伴！没错！办公室女士网络现在将由奥德赛（Odyssey）发布。我们对这个新合作感到非常兴奋。
You know, we said we did not want to stop podcasting when this rewatch is over, and Odyssey is so excited to help us craft the next phase of Office Ladies. They are also releasing The Lazy Genius, and hopefully we're gonna be able to develop even more awesome podcasts for the Office Ladies Network. It was a big decision. It was a huge decision.
你知道，我们说过，当这次重温结束时，我们不想停止做播客，而奥德赛非常高兴能帮助我们打造办公室女士的下一阶段。他们还将发布《懒人格局》（The Lazy Genius），希望我们能够为办公室女士网络开发更多精彩的播客。这是一个重大的决定。这是一个巨大的决定。
For me, I just think sometimes change is good because it infuses you with a big decision. It was a huge decision. For me, I just think sometimes change is good, because it infuses you with a new energy. We are coming up on our five-year anniversary of podcasting. Five years. Yes. Holy moly. Sometimes it's good to shake things up a little
对我来说，我只是觉得有时候改变是好的，因为它会为你注入一个重大的决定。这是一个巨大的决定。对我来说，我只是觉得有时候改变是好的，因为它会为你注入新的活力。我们即将迎来播客五周年纪念日。五年。是的。天哪。有时候，稍微改变一下现状是件好事
to keep it fresh. Well, lady, you know, change normally scares the bejesus out of me. But this all just felt right. You know those moments in life when you have a big decision to make, but somehow it felt easy because everything you were feeling just felt so natural?
为了保持新鲜感。好吧，女士，你知道，改变通常会把我吓个半死。但这一切感觉都挺对的。你知道生活中总会有一些时刻，当你需要做一个重大决定时，不知为何它感觉很简单，因为你所有的感受都那么自然？
That's really how I felt. I feel like this is our next organic step for office ladies. And I have to say, I was really thankful to have you during all those conversations, Jenna, because you're the person who I bounce life off of. You're the person who, this is like my biggest career adventure, this whole podcast with you. And we talked it out.
这确实是我的感受。我觉得这是我们办公室女士下一个自然的步骤。我必须说，珍娜，在所有这些谈话中，我真的很庆幸有你相伴，因为你是我倾诉生活的人。你是我身边的人，整个播客，这就像我最大的职业冒险，我和你一起完成的。我们讨论过了。
We talked it out. I said to Lee, I was so glad that you were my partner in all of it, too. We can do anything when we do it together ladies. That's how I feel. That's how I feel. And now I just feel so excited. And honestly, I'm kind of giddy about the next chapter.
我们讨论过了。我对李说，我也很高兴在这一切中你是我的合作伙伴。女士们，当我们一起行动时，我们可以做到任何事情。我的感觉就是这样。这就是我的感受。现在我感到非常兴奋。老实说，对于下一个篇章，我有点晕乎乎的兴奋。
And I just feel so thankful that I get to keep doing this podcast, this thing that I love with my best friend. And now we have this awesome team at Odyssey. Everyone there is so nice and enthusiastic. And I'm excited. Well, I think one of the funny things is that our new, I guess, boss, you would call her, she's the executive vice president of podcasts at Odyssey. Her name is also Jenna.
我感到非常庆幸，我能继续做这个播客，做这件我热爱的事，和我的最好朋友在一起。现在我们在奥德赛拥有了这个超棒的团队。那里的每个人都非常友好和热情。我很兴奋。嗯，我觉得有趣的一件事情是，我们的新老板——姑且这么称呼她吧，她是奥德赛播客执行副总裁。她的名字也叫珍娜。
Yeah, we have two Jennas spelled the same way. Yes. And so now when we do Zooms, I never know if a question is for me or if it's for the other Jenna. Like recently, we were doing that Zoom and someone was like, Jenna, would you like to weigh in on the marketing outline? And I was like, oh, I didn't know I was going to have to talk about that. Yeah, you look like a deer in headlights. You're like, what? We're like, no, that's Jenna Weis-Berman.
对，我们有两个拼写相同的珍娜。是的。所以现在当我们开Zoom会议时，我从来不知道一个问题是针对我的，还是针对另一个珍娜的。比如最近，我们正在开那个Zoom会议，有人说，珍娜，你想对营销大纲发表一下看法吗？然后我就想，哦，我不知道我还得谈论这个。对，你看上去就像一只在车灯前受惊的小鹿。你会想，什么？我们就会说，不，那是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼。
Yes, we've started calling her JWB. Yeah, JWB. Weiss Berman. Yes. We've started calling her JWB. Yeah. JWB. And she's awesome. She is so awesome. Well, I think for our second piece of news, I'm going to call this announcement Tickled Pink. OK.
是的，我们开始叫她JWB。对，JWB。韦斯·伯曼。是的。我们开始叫她JWB。对。JWB。她太棒了。她真的太棒了。好吧，我觉得对于我们的第二条消息，我将把这个公告称为“欣喜若狂”。好的。
Because I am just tickled pink because Cassie Jerkins, our fantastic lead producer, is coming with us to Odyssey. Yes, Cassie, say hi to everybody. Hi. Woohoo! You know what? I'm so excited. This is making me so happy.
因为我简直欣喜若狂，因为我们出色的首席制作人卡西·杰金斯将和我们一起去奥德赛。是的，卡西，向大家打个招呼。嗨。呜呼！你知道吗？我太兴奋了。这让我太开心了。
I think I need to hear my happy song. Okay. You remember in season seven, Ultimatum, Michael finds out that Holly is not engaged. Yeah. And so him and Erin go in his office and he watches that video of himself and he plays this happy song.
我想我需要听我的开心歌。好的。你还记得第七季的《最后通牒》吗，迈克尔发现霍莉没有订婚。是的。所以他和艾琳走进他的办公室，他看着那段自己的视频，然后播放了这首开心歌。
You love the whole concept of a happy song. Lady, I have a new happy song. I have a new happy musical group. Oh. It's ABBA. Yes, you said it right. I know, I've always sang it to you wrong. I know.
你喜欢“开心歌”整个这个概念。女士，我有一首新的开心歌。我有一个新的开心音乐组合。哦。是ABBA。是的，你发音对了。我知道，我以前总是读错。我知道。
Jenna sometimes says ABBA. I don't know why. It's Abba, and I love them. And you know I love them so much. I'm trying to get Angela to dress up for Halloween as the two ladies from Abba with me. I know. This is my quest.
珍娜有时会说ABBA。我不知道为什么。是Abba，我爱死他们了。你知道我有多爱他们。我正试图让安吉拉在万圣节打扮成Abba里的两位女士和我一起。我知道。这是我的追求。
It's ever since I watched Muriel's wedding. Okay, this is a long explanation, but my new happy song is Gimmie, Gimmie, Gimmie by ABBA. Sam, can you play it? Oh! That's right, everybody. You heard me. Sam is back.
自从我看过《穆丽尔的婚礼》以来就是这样。好吧，这是一个很长的解释，但我的新开心歌是ABBA的《Gimmie, Gimmie, Gimmie》。山姆，你能放一下吗？哦！没错，各位。你们没听错。山姆回来了。
Sam is here. Hi, everyone. Oh my God. Hi. Yeah. Woo! Woo! That's right, everyone.
山姆在这里。大家好。哦天哪。嗨。耶。呜！呜！没错，各位。
Odyssey helped us bring Sam back to finish the rewatch and now our OG Office Ladies team is together. Yay! Oh boy. Thank you for having me back. Aw, Sam! This is the best. Do, do, do.
奥德赛帮助我们把山姆请了回来，以完成重温工作，现在我们最初的办公室女士团队又聚在一起了。耶！哦天哪。谢谢你们欢迎我回来。啊，山姆！太棒了。哒，哒，哒。
I like it. I like it. You like it. Yeah, I like it. Okay. All right. Finally, Office Ladies News number three. I don't have a title for this, but I do have an audio clip to kick it off.
我喜欢。我喜欢。你喜欢。对，我喜欢。好的。好了。最后，办公室女士新闻第三条。我没有为这个起标题，但我有一段音频剪辑来拉开序幕。
I don't know what it is. I know you don't. Sam, will you play my special audio clip? And Cassie, come on in here. Oh my gosh. I'm on three. on in here. Oh my gosh. Angela Kinsey, you've got a birthday coming up my friend. Oh my Who hide those? They're enormous. Yay! Yay! Woo! Yeah. It is your birthday, Anna.
我不知道是什么。我知道你不知道。山姆，你能播放我的特别音频剪辑吗？还有卡西，快进来。哦天哪。我在三。快进来。哦天哪。安吉拉·金西，我的朋友，你快过生日了。哦，天哪。谁把那些藏起来了？它们太巨大了。耶！耶！呜！耶。安娜，今天是你的生日。
It is my birthday. I am 53. Holy cow. Woo! And listen, because this episode has a cupcake theme, I brought you cupcakes as your sweet treat. Oh my gosh. I am so excited. I brought you cupcakes as your sweet treat. Oh my gosh. I am so excited.
今天是我的生日。我53岁了。天哪！呜！听着，因为这一集有一个纸杯蛋糕的主题，我给你带了纸杯蛋糕作为甜点。哦天哪。我太激动了。我给你带了纸杯蛋糕作为甜点。哦天哪。我太激动了。
I know. I sent the team an email asking everyone their favorite cupcake flavor, and it was all a ruse to find out what cupcake you like for your birthday lady. Aw. You guys, I'm so excited. I love a birthday.
我知道。我给团队发了一封邮件，询问每个人最喜欢的纸杯蛋糕口味，这全是个诡计，为了弄清楚你这位女士生日喜欢吃什么纸杯蛋糕。啊。你们，我太激动了。我喜欢过生日。
And a birthday surprise. Did we get you? You totally got me. I had no idea. I love a birthday. And a birthday surprise. Did we get you? You totally got me. I had no idea. Well played. Well played. I mean, I think next to a donut, I love a cupcake so much because it's a cake that you can hold in your hand, you guys.
还有一个生日惊喜。我们骗到你了吗？你们完全把我骗了。我一点都不知道。我喜欢过生日。还有一个生日惊喜。我们骗到你了吗？你们完全把我骗了。我一点都不知道。干得漂亮。干得漂亮。我是说，我觉得除了甜甜圈，我最喜欢的就是纸杯蛋糕了，因为这是一种你可以拿在手里的蛋糕，各位。
I know. It's everything you love in a cake, but you can just carry it with you. How wonderful is that? Do you want to open up your gift? Yes. Okay. Oh my gosh. You really surprised me. Okay. Oh my God. There's so many things in here. Well, you only have to open up one of them because they're all the same. Okay. There's four things. They're wrapped in paper. Oh my gosh! They are the most beautiful glasses with hand painted,
我知道。这就是你对蛋糕的所有喜爱，但你可以随身携带。这有多棒啊？你想打开你的礼物吗？好的。哦天哪。你真的给了我一个惊喜。好的。哦天哪。这里有好多东西。好吧，你只需要打开其中一个，因为它们都是一样的。好的。有四样东西。它们用纸包着。哦天哪！它们是最美的杯子，上面有手绘的，
it looks like hand painted hummingbirds on them and flowers and bumblebees and I am, I love it so much. It's for your home office. Oh my gosh. Yeah. Please, please take a picture of me. Of course I will.
看起来像是手绘蜂鸟和花朵还有大黄蜂，我，我太喜欢了。这是给你家庭办公室用的。哦天哪。是的。请，请帮我拍张照片。我当然会。
Look, Cassie, did you see these? Sam, Sam, it's a hummingbird. Oh, hummingbird in flowers. You know when someone just really gets you and they bring you cake you can hold in your hand and a glass with all the things you love on it. Yes. Lady, thank you so much. Well, that is our top of show, which is basically just a bunch of celebration. And we're going to take that energy into our
看，卡西，你看到这些了吗？山姆，山姆，这是一只蜂鸟。哦，花丛中的蜂鸟。你知道当一个人真正懂你，给你带了你可以拿在手里的蛋糕，还有一个印满你喜爱事物的杯子时那种感觉吗。是的。女士，非常感谢。好吧，这就是我们的节目开场，基本上就是一堆庆祝活动。我们将把这种能量带入我们对
breakdown of the farm. We'll take a break. We'll be right back. We'll be right back. We'll be right back. All right. We are back. We are breaking down the farm. And I'm going to start off with a summary. Okay. Dwight's aunt Shirley has died. And Oscar is the only co-worker invited to attend the funeral. Yeah. Dwight's Aunt Shirley has died and Oscar is the only co-worker invited to attend the funeral. Yeah. We will discuss. Mm-hmm. We learn that Dwight has a brother and a sister and that the three siblings have inherited Aunt Shirley's farm. Meanwhile, Todd Packer visits the Scranton branch to make amends
《农场》的剖析中。我们休息一下。马上回来。马上回来。马上回来。好的。我们回来了。我们在剖析《农场》。我先做一个总结。好的。德怀特的姨妈雪莉去世了。奥斯卡是唯一一个受邀参加葬礼的同事。是的。德怀特的姨妈雪莉去世了，奥斯卡是唯一一个受邀参加葬礼的同事。是的。我们将进行讨论。嗯-hmm。我们得知德怀特有一个兄弟和一个姐妹，这三个兄弟姐妹继承了雪莉姨妈的农场。与此同时，托德·帕克来到斯克兰顿分公司，通过分发特殊的纸杯蛋糕来弥补
for his past bad deeds by handing out special cupcakes in exchange for forgiveness. So I think we should start by reminding people that when season nine started, we all knew that Rainn Wilson was originally only contracted to do 13 episodes of The Office. And this was because he was developing a new show, an office spinoff called The Farm, which was being written by Paul Lieberstein. This is that episode, sort of. They shot this episode in August, right before Labor Day, and the plan was that if the show got picked up,
他过去做过的坏事，以换取原谅。所以我觉得我们应该先提醒大家，当第九季开始时，我们都知道雷恩·威尔逊最初只签约出演13集《办公室》。这是因为他当时在开发一个新节目，一个名为《农场》的办公室衍生剧，由保罗·利伯斯坦编剧。这就是那一集，差不多吧。他们在8月份、劳动节前夕拍摄了这一集，计划是如果这个节目被选中，
then it would start running in January as a mid-season show, and it would kind of overlap with The Office. The Office would air as a lead-in and then The Farm would air after, so you'd get a few months of both shows before the office was over. But by like November, December, they found out that farm was not going to get picked up. And the writers had to kind of scramble to fit Dwight back into the greater story of The Office starting in January.
那么它就会在1月份作为季中剧开始播出，并且会与《办公室》有所重叠。《办公室》作为先导剧播出，然后《农场》在后面播出，这样在《办公室》结束前，你就可以看到几个月的两部剧。但到了11月、12月左右，他们发现《农场》不会被选中了。编剧们不得不手忙脚乱地把德怀特重新塞回1月份开始的《办公室》宏大故事线中。
And then they also decided to like air this pilot episode as an episode of The Office. Yeah. You know, Rain did an interview with Larry King where he talked about the farm and what happened with it and we thought we'd play it. Here's what he had to say.
然后他们还决定把这个试播集作为《办公室》的一集来播出。是的。你知道，雷恩接受了拉里·金的采访，他在采访中谈到了《农场》以及后来发生的事情，我们觉得可以放给大家听听。他是这么说的。
You filmed a spin-off of The Office focused on Dwight's life on his beet farm, NBC passed on it. Will we ever see it? You are gonna see it. It's called The Farm and we shot it as, they call it a backdoor pilot. So it stands as an episode of The Office,
你拍了一部衍生自《办公室》的剧集，聚焦于德怀特在甜菜农场的的生活，NBC放弃了它。我们还能看到它吗？你们会看到的。它叫《农场》，我们把它作为所谓的“后门试播集”拍摄的。所以它作为《办公室》的一集存在，
where there's a funeral on Dwight's farm, and you get to meet other members of Dwight's family. When will we see it? I don't know when the air date is, but there's gonna be an episode of The Office called The Farm that's gonna contain a good chunk. Most of the material that we shot for the pilot will be seen just as a regular Office episode.
其中德怀特的农场上有一场葬礼，你还会见到德怀特家族的其他成员。我们什么时候能看到它？我不知道播出日期是什么时候，但会有一集名为《农场》的《办公室》，其中包含很大一部分。我们为试播集拍摄的大部分素材都将作为常规的《办公室》剧集播出。
You wanted it to be a series, right? I wanted it to be a series, but I was in this great situation too because I wanted it to be a series, I thought it was a really fun idea to be out on Dwight's crazy beat farm, but I'm also equally happy to be hanging up my terrible haircut and my terrible glasses
你希望它成为一个系列，对吧？我希望它成为一个系列，但我当时的处境也很好，因为我希望它成为一个系列，我觉得在德怀特疯狂的甜菜农场上拍摄是一个非常有趣的想法，但与此同时，我也同样高兴能在3月中旬结束时挂起我糟糕的发型和糟糕的眼镜，
at the end of it in mid-March and be done with Dwight and put him to bed. And it's been a great run. So that's kind of how it went down. But the other thing is that they only ended up using 12 minutes of the farm pilot. Yeah. I read the whole thing. I had the shooting draft, you know, we both have it. It's a whole full episode.
和德怀特说再见，让他入睡。这是一段美好的旅程。所以事情大致就是这样。但另一件事是，他们最后只用了《农场》试播集12分钟的镜头。是的。我读了全部内容。我有拍摄剧本，你知道的，我们俩都有。这是一整集完整的剧集。
Rain also did an interview with Office Tally where he said scenes had to be trimmed like we're talking about and removed because they included plot points that pointed to Dwight leaving Dunder Mifflin and moving to the farm full time. So it kind of resulted in a little bit of a clunky episode, right?
雷恩还接受了Office Tally的采访，他在采访中表示，场景必须像我们讨论的那样进行精简和删除，因为它们包含了一些情节指向，表明德怀特将离开邓德米夫林，全职搬到农场。所以这导致这一集显得有点笨拙，对吧？
Yeah, I read some reviews and people said they could tell that you weren't really getting the full farm pilot experience, that it felt a little one place called it like a Frankenstein episode. Yeah. Like we added this whole cupcake storyline later because originally the folks back at the office
是的，我读了一些评论，人们说他们能看出你并没有真正获得完整的《农场》试播集体验，感觉有点像一个地方称之为“弗兰肯斯坦式的剧集”。是的。就像我们后来添加了这个纸杯蛋糕的剧情线，因为最初办公室里的伙计们
only appeared in the cold open. Yeah. We weren't in the rest of the episode. Yeah, you know, Steve office only appeared in the cold open. Yeah. We weren't in the rest of the episode. Yeah, you know, Steve Burgess sends us the call sheets. We love Steve and photos of his yard every week. I love it so much. And we saw they filmed the farm, end of August, early September of 2012.
只出现在冷开场中。是的。我们没有出现在剧集的其余部分。是的，你知道，史蒂夫·伯吉斯给我们发了通告单。我们爱史蒂夫，他每周都会发他院子的照片。我太喜欢了。我们看到他们拍摄《农场》是在2012年8月底、9月初。
But those scenes you're talking about, lady with the cupcakes and all that, we filmed in February of 2013. Mm-hmm. It was a long time later. Well, speaking of the scenes we were in, one of the ones that was in the shooting draft from the very beginning was this cold open. Yeah, Dwight arrives to work.
但你刚才说的那些场景，有纸杯蛋糕和所有这些的女士，我们是在2013年2月拍摄的。嗯-hmm。那是很久以后了。嗯，说到我们参与的场景，从一开始就在拍摄剧本里的场景之一就是这个冷开场。是的，德怀特来上班了。
He is in a suit and a top hat. Creed says, nice glasses. Yeah. Erin says he looks like a fancy clown. Yes, and this is when Dwight informs her he is dressed according to the Shroot codes of mourning because his aunt Shirley has died
他穿着西装，戴着大礼帽。克里德说，好眼镜。是的。艾琳说他看起来像个滑稽的小丑。是的，这就是德怀特通知她他正按照施鲁特家族的哀悼准则着装的时候，因为他的姨妈雪莉去世了，
and she was the closest thing he had to a mother. And then he has a talking head where he says, actually his mother was cold and distant and was the closest thing he had to an aunt. Yes. Dwight is carrying two tiny buckets. We learn that they are filled with soil, and he will either throw red fertile dirt in your face,
而她是他最接近母亲的人。然后他有一个独白，说实际上他的母亲冷漠而疏离，是他最接近姨妈的人。是的。德怀特提着两个小桶。我们得知里面装满了泥土，他要么会把红色肥沃的泥土泼在你脸上，
which means you are invited to the funeral, or he's going to throw black, slightly acidic soil on your face, and that means you are not invited to the funeral. I was very curious about this because my dad used to always say black soil is the richest soil. Oh. And that red dirt is not as great at growing things.
这意味着你被邀请参加葬礼，要么他会把黑色、略带酸性的泥土泼在你脸上，这意味着你没有被邀请参加葬礼。我对这个很好奇，因为我爸爸以前总是说黑土是最肥沃的土壤。哦。红土对植物生长的效果没那么好。
Oh. And I looked it up, and there's a lot of information about soil out there. I thought I would share it, but that's a whole other podcast called Soil. Well, did you find out if the color of the soil points to its fertility? Natalia No. I don't know.
哦。我查了一下，网上有很多关于土壤的信息。我本想分享一下，但这其实是另一个叫《土壤》的播客。好吧，你有没有发现土壤的颜色是否指向它的肥力？娜塔莉亚 没有。我不知道。
Maybe this is my dad as a farmer, his just like, you know, how farmers have their little sayings like, oh, when the storms come in, the cows go and line up by the fence. You know what I mean? Those kind of sayings. Amy My dad never heard that saying, but I also did not grow up on a farm, but I like it. Natalia My dad would say things like this. Amy Yeah. Okay.
也许这就是我爸爸作为农民的习惯，你知道的，就像农民有他们的小俗语一样，比如，哦，暴风雨来临时，奶牛会排队靠在栅栏旁。你知道我的意思吗？那种俗语。艾米 我爸爸从来没听过那个俗语，但我也没有在农场长大，不过我喜欢这个。娜塔莉亚 我爸爸就会说这样的话。艾米 是的。好吧。
Well, Dwight is now going to walk around and start throwing soil on people. He starts with Erin. She gets black soil. So does Phyllis. So does Kevin. Then he gets to Oscar and he reaches into the black soil bucket and Oscar is like, oh, thank God. He's so relieved.
好吧，德怀特现在要四处走动，开始把泥土泼在人们身上。他从艾琳开始。她得到了黑土。菲利斯也是。凯文也是。然后他走到奥斯卡面前，把手伸进黑土桶里，奥斯卡就像是，哦，谢天谢地。他如释重负。
I have an improv moment by Oscar. Oh, please. So it was scripted where Oscar would say, I'm so sorry, Dwight. If you want me to be there, of course I will go. And then Oscar improvised this. I just, I have a personal training session. That was an improv.
我有一个奥斯卡的即兴发挥时刻。哦，请讲。剧本里写的是奥斯卡会说，我非常抱歉，德怀特。如果你想让我去，我当然会去。然后奥斯卡即兴发挥了这句。我只是，我有一个私人训练课程。那是即兴发挥。
I also have something to point out at one minute, 16 seconds. Is it your insane hair? My amazing braid catch! Yes! Big shout out to Kim Ferry for creating this very intricate Angela Martin braid. That is all of my actual hair. I don't know how she got it to look like that. Well this is something that is true of you and Kim in later seasons, which is that if
我还有一处要在1分16秒时指出来。是你那疯狂的头发吗？我惊艳的编发！是的！大声感谢金·费里（Kim Ferry）创作了这门非常复杂的安吉拉·马丁式编发。那全部都是我真实的头发。我不知道她是怎麽弄成那个样子的。嗯，这是你和金在后来的几季中都有的一个特点，那就是如果
the cold open was set on a different day than the rest of the episode, you and Kim would do an elaborate braid. Yes. Because you only had to wear it for a few hours. Exactly. So I noticed it. I was like, oh, there it is. That's a cold open braid.
冷开场设定的日期和剧集其余部分不在同一天，你和金就会做一个精致的编发。是的。因为你只需要戴几个小时。没错。所以我注意到了。我就想，哦，在那里。那是冷开场的编发。
Sure is. Well, guess what? Dwight changes his mind and he throws red soil in Oscar's face, which means Oscar is now going to the funeral. He has the best talking head. He really does. Oscar says, I get red dirt. Nobody is getting red dirt.
确实是。好吧，你猜怎麽着？德怀特改变了主意，他把红泥泼在奥斯卡脸上，这意味着奥斯卡现在要去参加葬礼了。他有一个最棒的独白。他真的有。奥斯卡说，我得到了红土。没人得到红土。
I should have kept my mouth shut. We're not even that close. I've only known Dwight 12 years. 12 years. Time is a son of a bitch. So the last person to get dirt is Jim, and Dwight is going to pack it very tightly into a dirt snowball, Jim says.
我本该闭上嘴的。我们甚至都没那么熟。我只认识德怀特12年。12年。时间真是个碧池。所以最后一个得到泥土的是吉姆，德怀特会把它紧紧地捏成一个泥雪球，吉姆说。
But before he throws it in Jim's face, we cut to the credits. We got a full-on fan mail flurry. People really wanna know, did Dwight actually throw dirt in our faces, and what was the dirt made of? I asked Steve Burgess, and he said it was dirt. It was specifically Fuller's earth.
但在他把它扔到吉姆脸上之前，镜头切到了职员表。我们收到了海量的粉丝来信。人们真的很想知道，德怀特真的把泥土砸在我们脸上了吗，泥土是用什么做的？我问了史蒂夫·伯吉斯，他说那就是泥土。具体来说是漂白土。
What is Fuller's earth? I guess it's a type of dirt. OK. I have such a strong memory that they threw crushed up Oreos on our faces. I had the same memory. Especially when Kevin licks a little off his lip. I thought it was crushed up Oreo.
什么是漂白土？我猜它是一种泥土。好的。我有种非常深刻的记忆，他们把压碎的奥利奥饼干扔在我们脸上了。我也有同样的记忆。尤其是当凯文舔掉嘴唇上的一点时。我以为那是碎奥利奥。
Did we do it in a rehearsal? Well, we did have a dirt test where they tested throwing dirt. And I know that while they would normally test this sort of stuff on our stand-ins, I was part of the test throw. And you and Ellie were as well. That's right.
我们在排练时做过这个吗？嗯，我们确实做过泥土测试，他们测试了扔泥土。我知道虽然他们通常会在我们的替身演员身上测试这种东西，但我也是测试投掷的参与者之一。你和埃莉也是。没错。
And so maybe they threw Oreos at us during the test throw and you and Ellie were as well. That's right. And so maybe they threw Oreos at us during the test and maybe they didn't stick or something. Well, it's interesting you say that about me, you and Ellie because I found something in my digital clutter. September 12th, 1148 a.m., Rainn Wilson emailed me, you and Ellie and the subject was titled Dirt Girls and it's a photo he took of the three of us with the fakie dirt on our faces. Yes, I love that picture.
所以也许他们在测试投掷时把奥利奥扔在我们身上，你和埃莉也是。没错。所以也许他们在测试时向我们扔了奥利奥，而它们可能没有粘住什么的。好吧，有趣的是你提到我和埃莉，因为我在我的数字杂物堆里找到了一些东西。9月12日上午11点48分，雷恩·威尔逊给我、你和埃莉发了一封电子邮件，主题是“泥土女孩”，里面有一张我们三个脸上带着假泥土的照片。是的，我喜欢那张照片。
I know. Did we put that in our book? We might have. We put like 400 photos in our book. I know. I think it might be one of them. OK. Well, we got some more fan questions
我知道。我们把那张照片放进我们的书里了吗？我们可能放了。我们在书里放了大约400张照片。我知道。我想它可能是其中之一。好的。好吧，我们收到了一些更多的粉丝提问
from Elizabeth P. in Toronto, Canada, who said, did Dwight actually throw the dirt ball in Jim's face before the scene cuts out? And Brittany Y. from Dana Point, California said, I have a prediction. I think in the cold open, Dwight throws the ceremonial dirt into Jim's face, but the reason it gets cut off at the end is because they couldn't get through it
来自加拿大多伦多的伊丽莎白·P，她问，在场景切走之前，德怀特真的把泥球扔到吉姆脸上了吗？来自加利福尼亚州达纳波因特的布兰妮·Y说，我有一个预测。我觉得在冷开场中，德怀特把仪式性的泥土扔进了吉姆的脸，但最后被切掉的原因是他们没法演下去，
and started laughing immediately after. Well, Brittany, that's a very good theory. Yeah. I will say I went to the script and it was scripted that Dwight, quote, nails Jim in the face. And you know Rain would have done it. Mm-hmm.
在拍完后立刻就笑场了。嗯，布兰妮，这是一个很好的理论。是的。我得说我去查了剧本，剧本里写的是德怀特“精准命中”了吉姆的脸。你知道雷恩会这么做的。嗯-hmm。
I don't remember what happened. I don't either. And I was sitting right there. I know. There was also originally a talking head at the end of this cold open. Dwight heads to his car. He's tossing the pails of dirt aside and ripping off his tux,
我不记得发生什么了。我也不记得了。我当时就坐在那儿。我知道。这个冷开场的结尾原本还有一个独白。德怀特走向他的车，他把泥桶扔到一边，脱掉燕尾服，
and he looks to Cameron and says, not a bad custom. I should tell the other shrewds something like this could really catch on. And then he kind of looks at the camera crew and goes, what? Oh, give me a break. My aunt just died. So it wasn't a custom at all for his family. Oh my gosh. He's such a s***.
他看着卡梅伦说，这习俗还真不错。我应该告诉其他施鲁特家族的人，这种事绝对能流行起来。然后他看了看摄像机组，说，什麽？哦，饶了我吧。我姨妈刚去世。所以这根本不是他家族的习俗。哦天哪。他真是个混蛋。
Is that the best prank Dwight has ever pulled? Maybe. That's gym level. That is gym level. He had to buy the suit, the top hat, although maybe he already owned that actually. I don't know. Well, I have a fun final tidbit about this cold open. Like you said, we shot this cold open back in September and it was during the same week that we were shooting Here Comes Treble. And you know, Here Comes Treble was our Halloween episode that year. So Steve Burgess said that we shot this on a Wednesday.
这是德怀特开过最棒的恶作礼吗？也许吧。那是吉姆级别的。那是吉姆级别的。他不得不买那套西装加大礼帽，不过也许他本来就有一套。我不知道。好吧，关于这个冷开场我还有一个有趣的小细节。就像你说的，我们是在9月份拍摄的这个冷开场，当时正值我们拍摄《这就是合唱团》的同一周。你知道，当年《这就是合唱团》是我们的万圣节特辑。所以史蒂夫·伯吉斯说我们是在周三拍摄的。
So on Tuesday night after work, the crew had to take down all of the Halloween decorations on the set that were there for Here Comes Treble and then had to put them back up after we finished this cold open. They had to de-Halloween and re-Halloween. Oh my gosh. In one night.
所以在周二下班后，剧组不得不拆掉片场为了《这就是合唱团》而设立的所有万圣节装饰，然后在我们拍完这个冷开场后又不得不把它们装回去。他们不得不去万圣节化和重新万圣节化。哦天哪。在一个晚上。
In one night. I don't know if anyone made a dirt in the face breakdown. Oh. Anyone out there who watched it, but we listed off who got the dirt, but one person who I never saw get dirt was Nellie. Oh yeah, you're right. Yeah.
在一个晚上。我不知道有没有人做过泥土击中脸部的统计。哦。任何看过的人，我们列出了谁被泥土击中了，但我从来没看到被泥土击中的人是耐莉。哦对，你说的对。是的。
I have one last thing to say about this scene. I don't know if you noticed that everyone that got dirt in their face at the top of the scene had to keep the dirt on their face for the entire rest of the scene. So if you go to one minute and 53 seconds, you will see Brian Baumgartner and I standing in the background with dirt on our faces
关于这个场景我还有最后一句话要说。我不知道你有没有注意到，场景开头所有脸上被扔了泥土的人，在整个场景的剩余部分都得把泥土留在脸上。所以如果你去到1分53秒，你会看到我和布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳站在背景里，脸上带着泥土，
while there's a scene going on with Jim and Pam and Dwight. However, in that scene with Jim, Pam and Dwight, Dwight throws a little dirt in Pam's face, but then when they cut back later to that same angle, I don't really have any on my face. Do you not? I think he would, sometimes there would be a take
当时吉姆、帕姆和德怀特正在演对手戏。然而，在吉姆、帕姆和德怀特的那个场景中，德怀特往帕姆脸上扔了一点泥土，但后来当他们切回那个相同角度时，我脸上其实没有泥土了。你没有吗？我想会的，有时会有一个镜头
where he would hit me, and sometimes there would be a take where he missed me. So I think they use different takes in their cut. But I go from having dirt to no dirt. Well, Brian and I got direct hits. All right, well now this episode is going to begin. Dwight and Moze are on the front porch as Moze plays guitar.
他打中了我，有时会有一个镜头他没打中。所以我想他们在剪辑时用了不同的镜头。但我经历了从有泥土到没有泥土的过程。好吧，我和布赖恩可是结结实实挨了一下。好吧，现在这一集要正式开始了。德怀特和莫斯坐在前廊上，莫斯在弹吉他。
He's playing Oklahoma. I have how it was described in the shooting draft. Would you like to hear it? I would. What if you said no? Then you would not be able to read it. Why do we ask? I know.
他弹奏的是《俄克拉荷马》。我有拍摄剧本里是怎么描述的。你想听听吗？我想。如果你说不想呢？那你就没法读了。我们为什么还要问呢？我知道。
We do it all the time. You're like, do you want to hear a summary? Yeah. Okay. Sure. Here's what it said. Dwight wearing funeral clothes paces nervously on the front porch, checking his watch. Mo's on the bench swing plays guitar, slowly picking out, Oh, what a beautiful morning
我们总是这样。你会说，你想听总结吗？是的。好吧。当然。上面是这么写的。德怀特穿着葬礼服装在前廊神经质地踱步，看着手表。莫斯在长椅秋千上弹着吉他，慢慢地拨弄出《俄克拉荷马》中的《哦，多美好的早晨》
from Oklahoma. Zeke rides up on a 1940s German motorcycle with a sidecar. Well, I should let everybody know that while Mike Schur as Moe's makes a brief appearance in this episode, he would not have been a regular character on the spinoff of the farm. You know, it's interesting because in the script,
齐克骑着一辆带边车的1940年代德国摩托车驶来。嗯，我应该让大家知道，虽然迈克·舒尔饰演的莫斯在本集中短暂出场，但他不会是《农场》衍生剧中的常规角色。你知道，这很有趣，因为在剧本中，
they found a creative way to make sure he didn't have to be on any other day but this day. Really? Yeah, so this is how it read in the shooting draft. Dwight walks to the motorcycle, Moe stays put and Dwight notices. Dwight says, you coming? Moe says, will there be ghosts there?
他们找到了一种有创意的方法，确保他除了这一天之外不需要出现在任何其他日子里。真的吗？是的，拍摄剧本里是这样写的。德怀特走向摩托车，莫斯呆在原地，德怀特注意到了。德怀特说，你来吗？莫斯说，那里面会有鬼吗？
Dwight says, you know, I can't say for sure. Moe says, I better not risk it. So he doesn't go. Well, Zeke, who can't say for sure. Most says, I better not risk it. So he doesn't go. Well, Zeke, who was played by Matt Jones, would have been a regular character on the show. You know, we originally introduced him in the Junior Salesman episode. That's when Dwight is trying to hire one of his friends
德怀特说，你知道的，我不能确定。莫斯说，我还是别冒险了。所以他没去。好吧，由马特·琼斯饰演的齐克，本来会是剧中的常规角色。你知道，我们最初是在《初级推销员》那一集中介绍他的。那是德怀特试图在他的朋友中雇佣一人
to work in the office. We filmed Junior Salesman after the farm. Oh. And we will also see the character of Zeke after the farm. Oh. Mm-hmm. And we will also see the character of Zeke in the finale. I thought maybe you would want a location breakdown. I always want a location breakdown. Yes.
来办公室工作的时候。我们是在《农场》之后拍摄的《初级推销员》。哦。我们还将在《农场》之后看到齐克这个角色。哦。嗯-hmm。我们还将在大结局中看到齐克这个角色。我以为你可能会想要一份取景地剖析。我总是想要一份取景地剖析。是的。
So you know, as Dwight and Zeke are bickering over who's going to sit in the sidecar, I noticed they were squinting quite a bit from the blazing sun that was beating down on them. So I thought maybe I would give you all a location breakdown. We filmed the farm at the Disney Ranch. This is the same place as Shroop Farms. Like you said before, Angelo, we filmed this at the end of August, beginning of September. And Steve Burgess said he remembered it was very hot.
所以你知道，当德怀特和齐克为谁坐在边车里而争吵时，我注意到他们因为毒辣的阳光直射而有些眯起眼睛。所以我想也许我可以给大家提供一份取景地剖析。我们在迪士尼牧场拍摄了《农场》。这和施鲁特农场是同一个地方。就像你之前说的，安吉拉，我们是在8月底9月初拍摄的。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说他记得当时非常热。
We also shot this episode for seven days. A normal office episode, we would only get five days. But they usually give you more time to shoot a pilot episode because creatively, you want that extra time so you can do more takes, you can figure things out, maybe rewrite things in the moment, because you're kind of still getting your bearings.
我们还为这一集拍摄了七天。正常的办公室剧集我们通常只有五天。但通常会给试播集更多的时间来拍摄，因为在创意上，你需要额外的时间来多拍几个镜头，把事情理清楚，也许当场重写一些东西，因为你还在适应和摸索中。
Yeah, well, Steve also shared with us a memo that he sent out to the cast and crew. Oh my gosh, I saw this. This is so great. I'm going to read it. Some things to remember went on location for episode 9005, The Farm. We will be working in desert-like conditions. During the day, we expect temperatures to exceed 90 degrees. Please stay hydrated. Electrolytes and sunscreen will be available with the medic. Buckets of ice water will be available around set. At night and next
是的，史蒂夫还跟我们分享了一份他发给演员和剧组的备忘录。哦天哪，我看到这个了。这太棒了。我要读一下。去第9005集《农场》外景地时需要记住的一些事情。我们将在沙漠般的环境中工作。白天，我们预计气温将超过90华氏度。请保持水分。医务人员处将提供电解质和防晒霜。片场周围将提供冰水桶。在晚上和下周
week in the early morning hours, we will have cooler temperatures, so please bring layers so you can stay warm. This next paragraph. Critters have been found in high volume around location. We have a full-time critter wrangler working with us. If you suspect there are critters in your area you are heading to or currently working in, please notify the wrangler and have him inspect the area. Despite the high temperatures, we encourage you to wear long pants and closed-toed protective shoes.
的清晨，气温会较低，所以请带上衣物以便保暖。这下一段。在外景地周围发现了大量的小动物。我们有一位全职的小动物管理员与我们合作。如果您怀疑您要前往或当前正在工作的区域有小动物，请通知管理员并让他检查该区域。尽管气温很高，我们还是建议您穿长裤和包头防护鞋。
This area has been known to have bees. Please alert the medic. Oh my gosh, critters and now bees. Please alert the medic if you are allergic. Be prepared and bring your EpiPen with you every day in case of an emergency. This is the same location where John bit into his scrambled eggs and bit into a bee, remember?
众所周知，这个区域有蜜蜂。请提醒医务人员。哦天哪，小动物，现在还有蜜蜂。如果您过敏，请提醒医务人员。做好准备，每天随身携带您的肾上腺素自动注射笔（EpiPen），以防万一。这就是约翰咬了一口炒鸡蛋结果咬到一只蜜蜂的同一个地方，记得吗？
Yes, during garden party. Yes. Lady, I'll have you know, I've started reading the back of the call sheets. Oh, they're delicious. It's a list of every crew member and what time they needed to arrive on set. By Wednesday, we had two critter wranglers.
是的，在花园派对期间。是的。女士，我要让你知道，我开始阅读通告单的背面了。哦，它们太精彩了。上面列出了每个剧组成员以及他们需要到达片场的时间。到周三的时候，我们有两个小动物管理员。
Oh gosh. Not one. They had to add an extra critter wrangler. Because it couldn't sound more. I know. All right, everyone has arrived at the burial site, including Oscar, who Dwight forgot he had invited. Yeah. This is when Dwight's brother Jeb arrives
哦天哪。不是一个。他们不得不增加了一个额外的小动物管理员。因为听起来不能再多了。我知道。好吧，每个人都到达了墓地，包括奥斯卡，德怀特忘了自己邀请了他。是的。这时候德怀特的兄弟杰布
in a red sports car, which he sort of drives into the grave. Yeah, it was described like this in the shooting draft. Okay. A rented Mustang drives up way too fast. The driver Jeb is excited to see Dwight and is waving and honking and not paying attention to where he's going. He drives right into the grave getting the front corner wheel stuck. He smiles and then gets out of the car. And they hug. Yeah. Jeb and Dwight seem very happy to see
开着一辆红色跑车赶到，他把车差不多直接开进了墓地。是的，拍摄剧本里是这样描述的。好的。一辆租来的野马开得太快了。司机杰布看到德怀特很兴奋，又挥手又按喇叭，根本没注意他在往哪里开。他直接把车开进了墓地，前角轮子卡住了。他笑了笑，然后下了车。然后他们拥抱了。是的。杰布和德怀特看起来很高兴见到
one another. Yeah, they start wrestling Dwight seem very happy to see one another. Yeah, they start wrestling and almost shoving each other into the gravesite. Lady. Yes? I have five bullsh** cards to play for this episode. Oh my goodness. I was not expecting you to say that.
彼此。是的，他们开始摔跤杰布和德怀特看起来很高兴见到彼此。是的，他们开始摔跤，差点把对方推进墓穴里。女士。什么？我有五张扯淡牌准备在这一集里打出来。哦天哪。我没想到你会这么说。
I probably could have more, but I narrowed it down to five. And I even made my own bulls**t cards. What? Josh help me. Let me grab my deck. Oh it's a deck of cards. This is like a magic trick now. Well there are five cards in here. I don't want to reveal. Let me make sure I have my right one. Okay. One second. This is also a royal flush. Oh yes, I did that on purpose. Thank you for noticing. I have a royal flush of bulls**t cards. I was gonna say that,
我可能还可以有更多，但我把它缩减到了五张。我甚至还制作了我自己的扯淡牌。什麽？乔希帮了我。让我拿一下我的牌组。哦，这是一副牌。这现在就像个魔术了。好吧，这里有五张牌。我不想透露。让我确保我拿到的是正确的。好的。等一下。这也是一个皇家同花顺。哦，是的，我是故意这么做的。谢谢你注意到。我有一套皇家同花顺的扯淡牌。我本来想这么说的，
but you're such a good card player, you beat me to it. Okay, I have my first bulls**t card I'm gonna play. It's the queen of hearts, everyone. It's the queen of hearts. Here it is. Jenna, I want you to describe my bullsh** card. Oh my God, this is amazing. Everyone, I wish now our podcast was on video
但你牌技太好了，抢在我前面了。好的，我要打出我的第一张扯淡牌。各位，是红桃Q。是红桃Q。在这里。珍娜，我想让你描述一下我的扯淡牌。哦天哪，这太棒了。各位，我真希望我们的播客现在是有视频的
just for this one moment. Please go to Office Ladies Pod. I'll share. She will share these bullsh** cards. It says bullsh**. Where's Angela? And it's a picture of Aunt Shirley and Angela together. Smiling at one another,
仅仅为了这一刻。请前往办公室女士播客。我会分享。她会分享这些扯淡牌。上面写着扯淡。安吉拉在哪里？这是一张雪莉姨妈和安吉拉在一起的照片。微笑着看着对方，
at the meal Angela cooked for her, after she had bathed her, in Moving On, Part Two. This is really, really incredible. You know, you aren't the only person who would like to play this bullsh** card. This was a fan mail flurry. Starting with Ludovico from Zurich.
在《继续前进，第二部分》中，安吉拉为她洗完澡后为她做的那顿饭。这真的是，真的是太不可思议了。你知道，可不止你一个人想打这张扯淡牌。这是一次粉丝来信狂潮。从苏黎世的卢多维科开始。
Oh, Ludovico, thank you. I'm surprised that Dwight didn't invite Pam or even Angela, who helped in his aunt's last moments. Thank you! Can you explain why so little of the cast goes to the funeral? And then we have Nick N. from Minnesota. My big question here is how was Angela meant to fit into this backdoor pilot? the cast goes to the funeral? And then we have Nick N from Minnesota.
哦，卢多维科，谢谢你。我很惊讶德怀特没有邀请帕姆，甚至连在德怀特姨妈生命的最后时刻给予帮助的安吉拉也没有邀请。谢谢！你能解释一下为什么这么少的演员去参加葬礼吗？然后我们有来自明尼苏达州的尼克·N。我这里最大的问题是，安吉拉原本打算如何融入这个后门试播集？演员去参加葬礼吗？然后我们有来自明尼苏达州的尼克·N。
My big question here is how was Angela meant to fit into this backdoor pilot? If it had been picked up, would Angela have been part of that show? I'm very interested to know what Dwight and Angela's future on the office would have looked like if the farm had been picked up. Oh, Nick.
我这里最大的问题是，安吉拉原本打算如何融入这个后门试播集？如果它被选中了，安吉拉会成为那个剧集的一部分吗？我很想知道，如果《农场》被选中了，德怀特和安吉拉在《办公室》里的未来会是什么样子。哦，尼克。
And then Jessica V from England said, I read that the farm was gonna to be a spinoff show for Dwight and his family on the farm. Angela, would you have been on this series too as Dwight obviously eventually married Angela? Were you contacted about signing on for this series? I love this fan mail flurry. I have some answers for you all.
然后来自英国的杰西卡·V说，我读到过《农场》将成为德怀特和他的家人在农场上的衍生剧。安吉拉，你也会在这个系列中出演吗，因为德怀特显然最终娶了安吉拉？你有没有被联系签约这个系列？我太喜欢这个粉丝来信狂潮了。我有一些答案要给你们所有人。
Yes. So Jessica, I wasn't contacted about the series, but one day Rain reached out to me. He said, Angela, I wasn't contacted about the series, but one day, Rain reached out to me. He said, Angela, I'd love to talk to you about the farm. And I went to his trailer on my lunch break. And he said, listen, he said, Ang, I'm gonna do this show.
是的。所以杰西卡，我没有被联系出演这个系列，但有一天雷恩联系了我。他说，安吉拉，我没有被联系出演这个系列，但有一天，雷恩联系了我。他说，安吉拉，我很想跟你聊聊关于《农场》的事。我在午休时间去了他的拖车。他说，听着，他说，安吉，我要做这个节目。
And he said, you know, I sort of saw your character like Lilith for the Frasier spinoff. You know, where Lilith is the for the Frasier spinoff. You know, where Lilith is the mother of Frasier's child and she pops in every once in a while. But really the show is about this new journey that Frasier's on. And that's how Rain told me he envisioned the show.
他说，你知道的，我有点把你的角色看作是《欢乐一家亲》（Frasier）衍生剧里的莉莉丝（Lilith）。你知道的，莉莉丝是Frasier的前妻，她偶尔会过来串场。但实际上这个节目是关于Frasier正在经历的新旅程。这就是雷恩告诉我他设想这个节目的方式。
They ended up not going that way. They ended up wanting to have a clean break that Dwight would be part of a whole new world, his family, on the farm, and they really didn't want my character kind of bogging down Dwight's future. So my character did not go to the funeral and was not included in the farm pilot. And here's what I think. I think that if this episode and this story of Aunt Shirley's funeral was just an office episode from the beginning, I think Pam and Angela would have been invited to this funeral. Right.
他们最后并没有按那个方向拍。他们最后想要一个干净的了结——德怀特将成为一个全新世界的一部分，留在农场的家里，而他们其实并不希望我的角色拖累德怀特的未来。所以我的角色没有去参加葬礼，也没有被纳入农场衍生剧的试播集。这就是我的想法：我觉得如果从一开始，这一集以及雪莉阿姨葬礼的故事就只是《办公室》的一集常规剧，我觉得帕姆和安吉拉是会被邀请参加这个葬礼的。对吧。
You would have seen more office people at this funeral. Exactly. If it wasn't written to be a spinoff. Exactly. There was actually a lot of the first half of season nine, particularly with the character Dwight, that was written with the idea that his character would be leaving in the middle of the first half of season nine, particularly with the character of Dwight, that was written with the idea that his character would be leaving in the middle of the season. And all of that had to be changed
你会在这场葬礼上看到更多办公室的人。没错。如果它不是被当成衍生剧来写的话。没错。其实第九季的前半部分有很多内容，尤其是关于德怀特这个角色的，在动笔时就默认他的角色会在第九季前半部分的中间离开，尤其是关于德怀特这个角色的，在动笔时就默认他的角色会在第九季前半部分的中间离开。而所有这些都必须做出更改
when the farm didn't move forward. Like, for example, the fact that the DNA test came back saying that Dwight was not Philip's father. That was done only because they were sort of already writing toward this idea that there was going to be this spinoff. Right, and Dwight and Angela needed a clean break. Exactly. You know, there was also that plot line, remember when Dwight finds the pills and he starts taking them? He was depressed
当《农场》衍生剧没能推进下去的时候。比如，DNA测试结果出来显示德怀特不是菲利普的父亲这一情节。这么写纯粹是因为他们当时已经在朝着会有这么一部衍生剧的方向去构思了。没错，而且德怀特和安吉拉需要一个干净的了结。没错。你知道的，还有那个剧情线，还记得德怀特找到药片并开始吃的时候吗？他当时在
at work. Yes, he was looking for a change. All of that was going to support him leaving Dunder Mifflin. all of that was going to support him leaving Dunder Mifflin. And remember everybody, moving on, that was written after the farm. And it was sort of to help give a lead in to this episode. And that's when your relationship with Aunt Shirley forms, but they had already filmed the farm. Yeah. So it's a little clunky.
工作中感到沮丧。是的，他当时在寻求改变。所有这些都是为了铺垫他离开邓德米福林。所有这些都是为了铺垫他离开邓德米福林。而且大家记住，那集“继续前行”是在《农场》之后写的。它某种程度上是为了给这一集做个引子。也就是在那时，你和雪莉阿姨的关系建立起来了，但他们当时已经把《农场》拍完了。对啊。所以它显得有点生硬。
Yeah. And it opens a lot of questions. Yeah. I get it. Well, I have a second bullsh** card to play now. Oh my gosh. So quickly. I'm so sorry. I love the cards so much and I can't wait to see this. Um, okay. Here is my second bullsh** card. Jenna, I'm going to give it to you. Okay. It just says, bullsh** brother? Two question marks and it's a picture of Jeb, Dwight's brother. Even Oscar is like, you have a brother? What?
对。而且这引发了很多疑问。对。我懂。好吧，我现在要打出第二张“胡扯”牌了。天哪。这么快。太对不起了。我很喜欢这些牌，而且我等不及要看这个了。嗯。好吧。这是我的第二张“胡扯”牌。珍娜，我要把它给你。好吧。上面写着：“胡扯”哥哥？两个问号，上面还有一张杰布（德怀特哥哥）的照片。连奥斯卡都一副“你还有个哥哥？”的表情。什么？
Yeah. Yeah. Apparently the farm was not subject to the office show Bible. No. We got to sort of just rewrite some history. I also have two more things from my digital clutter. My first one was the email from Rain. Here's my second one. I emailed you, Jenna, and I titled it, Question About Our Schedule. And I said, hey, I'm trying to plan a quick Thursday Sunday trip home to Texas with Isabel. I'm looking at
对啊。对啊。显然，《农场》不受《办公室》官方设定集（Show Bible）的约束。没错。我们基本上就是重写了一些历史。我从我的数码杂物箱里也找出了另外两样东西。我的第一件是雷恩发来的邮件。这是我的第二件。我给你发过邮件，珍娜，标题是《关于我们的日程安排》。我说，嘿，我正打算和伊莎贝尔一起进行一次周四到周日的闪电式回家探亲，回德克萨斯州。我在看
our schedule. What is the deal with the farm pilot episode anyway? Are we all in that episode? Do we work one day and then it's all Dwight? Jenna, you wrote back, they won't confirm. I was told. This is very funny. I've already researched this. I was told I'm only in the cold open
我们的日程安排。话说那个《农场》试播集到底是怎么回事？我们所有人都会出现在那一集里吗？我们是不是只工作一天，然后就全都是德怀特的内容了？珍娜，你回信说，他们不肯确认。我被告知——这太有趣了。我之前已经查过了。我被告知我只出现在开场前情提要（cold open）里，
and would only shoot one day and then have like five days off. But I was also told a couple of characters go to the farm for a couple of scenes. I don't know who. So. I love how you check in with me. I know. About the schedule. But I also would know that you had already looked into it.
而且只需要拍一天，然后大概会有五天假。但我还听说有几个角色会去农场拍几场戏。我不知道是谁。所以。我好喜欢你跟我核对行程。我知道。关于日程安排的事。但我也知道你其实早就已经查过了。
I had already looked into it. Well, we clearly did get that time off. And my third Digital Clutter email explains what we were doing. I'll share that later. I love it. Well, now we're going to go back to Dunder Mifflin, and this will start the added storyline of Todd Packer coming in with his cupcakes. This scene has two of my favorite Pam moments in the episode. The first one when Clark asks who Todd is and Pam just goes, bad.
我早就已经查过了。好吧，我们确实得到了那些假期。我的第三封数码杂物箱邮件解释了我们当时在干什么。我稍后会分享。我太喜欢了。好了，现在我们要回到邓德米福林，这将拉开托德·帕克带着纸杯蛋糕登场的加戏序幕。这场戏里有我在这一集中最喜欢的两个帕姆的高光时刻。第一个是克拉克问托德是谁，帕姆直接回答：“烂人。”
Jenna, you're so funny. Thank you. And then Todd addresses the bullpen. He says, you know what? I'm working through the steps of Alcoholics Anonymous and Narcotics Anonymous. He's there to make amends. He goes around the room and he starts apologizing to everyone, but actually insulting everyone. And this is my second favorite moment from Pam.
珍娜，你太逗了。谢谢。然后托德对开放式办公区的人说话。他说：“你知道吗？我正在经历匿名戒酒会和匿名戒毒会的各个阶段。”他是来道歉的。他在房间里转来转去，开始向每个人道歉，但实际上是在侮辱每个人。这是我最喜欢的帕姆的第二个高光时刻。
She goes, Todd, you're just saying insults in the form of an apology. Yes, this was really fun to shoot. I always enjoyed Todd Packer, even though none of our characters enjoyed Todd Packer. He definitely shakes everything up. He does. It's such a fun energy. This is when Todd Packer is going to announce that he has brought cupcakes for everyone from Nipples, I mean, Nibbles, at the Steamtown Mall. But Pam thinks everybody should have a private conversation before they accept this apology and eat their cupcake.
她说：“托德，你只是在用道歉的形式说侮辱人的话。”是的，拍这一段真的很有趣。我一直很喜欢托德·帕克，尽管我们剧里的角色没有一个人喜欢托德·帕克。他绝对把一切都搅得天翻地覆。确实如此。这能量太好玩了。就在这时，托德·帕克宣布他给大家带了纸杯蛋糕，是斯蒂姆敦购物中心的“乳头”——我是说，“尼布尔斯（Nibbles）”甜品店买的。但帕姆认为大家在接受这个道歉并吃纸杯蛋糕之前，应该先进行一次私下对话。
I do love that Pam is the one that says, it's Nibbles. Yeah, exactly. Well, back at the farm, the funeral has begun, the graveside service, and we have a guest star callback, Michael Tuba Heatherton is back. Tuba just cracks me up. How many times we kept bringing him back? In different roles.
我真的很喜欢帕姆那句：“是尼布尔斯。”对，没错。好吧，镜头回到农场，葬礼已经开始了，墓地悼词环节，我们迎来了一位客串演员的回归，迈克尔·图巴·希瑟顿又回来了。图巴简直让我笑死。我们到底让他回来过多少次？在不同的角色里。
Yes. He's now a minister. Season seven, he was in Andy's play as part of the cast for Sweeney Todd. Possible that he was a minister. Maybe so, you're right. Possible. And then in the seminar, he played the golf supply guy. Maybe his side hustle, maybe still a minister.
是的。他现在是个牧师了。第七季里，他在安迪的戏剧里演《理发师陶德》的剧组卡司。他当过牧师是有可能的。也许吧，你说的对。有可能。然后在研讨会上，他演了高尔夫用品店的人。也许那是他的副业，或者他现在依然是个牧师。
Perhaps. And now in season nine, he is the minister for Aunt Shirley's funeral, and then eventually, he marries Dwight and Angela. Wow. So he does play a minister twice. He does. Well, during this sermon, Jeb reaches down He marries Dwight and Angela. Wow. So he does play a minister twice. He does.
也许吧。现在到了第九季，他成了雪莉阿姨葬礼的牧师，最后还为德怀特和安吉拉主持了婚礼。哇。所以他真的演了两次牧师。他确实演了。好吧，在这场悼词期间，杰布弯下身去 他为德怀特和安吉拉主持了婚礼。哇。所以他真的演了两次牧师。他确实演了。
Well, during this sermon, Jeb reaches down and he tastes the soil. I guess he wants to know if it's worth anything. I Googled it. Tasting soil is a real thing. Yeah. According to an article from KTOO Garden Talk, quote, you can sometimes determine if the soil is too acidic or alkaline just by taste.
好吧，在这场悼词期间，杰布弯下腰去，尝了尝泥土。我猜他是想看看这地有没有什么价值。我谷歌了一下。尝泥土这事是真实存在的。对。根据《KTOO花园访谈》的一篇文章显示，引用：“你有时仅凭味道就能判断出土壤是酸性过高还是碱性过大。”
But they say, unlike Jeb, just chew it, don't swallow. You want to spit it out. They said kind of like a wine tasting. When sommeliers taste wine, they like sniff it and then they put it in their mouth and they swish it around, they actually spit it out. That's how you should taste your soil. Right.
但文章说，不像杰布那样，只管嚼，别咽下去。你应该把它吐出来。他们说这有点像品酒。当品酒师品尝葡萄酒时，他们会闻一闻，然后放进嘴里漱口，实际上他们会把它吐出来。这才是你品尝土壤的正确方式。对。
Well, apparently whatever Jeb tastes, he says is crap. He said nothing's going to grow there. And Dwight's like, nothing needs to grow here. It's a cemetery. We're not growing zombies. Mm-hmm. I just love that zombies made it in. I know.
好吧，显然无论杰布尝出什么味儿，他都说那是垃圾。他说这地方什么也长不出来。德怀特就说：“这地方不需要长出什么东西。这是个墓地。我们又不是在培育僵尸。”嗯哼。我太喜欢“僵尸”这个梗被塞进来了。我知道。
I thought it would make you happy. I do love zombies. I know. I really know. I thought it would make you happy. I do love zombies. I know. I really do. I thought of you. Thank you. I just think they're so scary. Yes.
我觉得这会让你高兴。我确实很喜欢僵尸。我知道。我真的很——我觉得这会让你高兴。我确实很喜欢僵尸。我知道。我真的。我想到了你。谢谢。我只是觉得它们太吓人了。对。
And amazing, but also you can survive them if you're crafty enough. You know what I mean? It's like they are slow. Well, the original zombie as crafted was slow, lumbering, but consistent. Nowadays, all the movies, oh, the zombies are fast all of a sudden.
而且很神奇，不过如果你足够机灵的话，你也能在它们手下活下来。你知道我的意思吗？就好像它们很慢。好吧，按设定最初的僵尸是很慢的、步履蹒跚的，但却锲而不舍。现在倒好，所有的电影里，噢，僵尸突然之间都变得飞快了。
You can probably tell from the tone of my voice how I feel about that development. You like OG zombies. I do. I like a slow, lumbering, relentless, determined zombie. But if I have my wits about me, I can hunker down in a mall or somewhere else. Right, you might just have to get used to, like,
你大概能从我说话的语气里听出我对这种发展的感受。你喜欢原汁原味的僵尸。我确实喜欢。我喜欢那种缓慢、步履蹒跚、毫不动摇、坚定不移的僵尸。但如果我保持机智，我就可以在一个购物中心或其他什么地方坚守阵地。对，你可能只需要习惯，比方说，
the constant thud of them smashing their face against the door repeatedly. But you can still live a life. They're dumb and slow, but always there. Right. I find that scarier, personally. Yeah, relentless. Yes. Anyway, that's my...
它们一次又一次把脸狠狠撞在门上的那种沉闷咚咚声。但你依然可以生活。它们又蠢又慢，但阴魂不散。对。就我个人而言，我觉得这更可怕。对，锲而不舍。是的。不管怎样，这就是我的……
Where were we? That's my zombie soapbox, everyone. Do you have a guest star breakdown? I do, actually, because we haven't done a guest star breakdown yet of Dwight's brother, Jeb Schrute, played by Thomas Middleditch. You know, he went on to become the star of Silicon Valley. He is also the voice of Harold
我们刚才说到哪了？这就是我的僵尸长篇大论，各位。你有什么客串演员盘点吗？我还真有，因为我们还没对德怀特的弟弟杰布·施鲁特进行过客串演员盘点呢，这个角色由托马斯·米德蒂奇扮演。你知道的，他后来成了《硅谷》的主演。他还是《内裤队长》电影里
in the Captain Underpants movie. He has appeared in a gazillion Verizon commercials. And according to the trivia on IMDb, he is a licensed pilot. Oh. And in a moment, Dwight's sister Fanny is gonna arrive with her son Cameron. She's beautiful. Oscar also didn't realize he had a sister.
哈罗德的配音。他出演过无数个威瑞森（Verizon）广告。根据IMDb上的花絮，他还是个拥有执照的飞行员。噢。过一会儿，德怀特的姐姐范妮会带着她的儿子卡梅隆到达。她长得很漂亮。奥斯卡之前也没意识到他还有一个姐姐。
Oh, I'm sorry. I thought didn't realize he had a sister. Oh, I'm sorry. I thought maybe you're reaching for your deck. I have a third bullsh** card. Here it is. Bullsh** sister? Question mark, question mark? With a photo of Fanny.
噢，对不起。我以为——没意识到他还有一个姐姐。噢，对不起。我以为也许你在伸手拿你的牌组。我有第三张“胡扯”牌。在这呢。“胡扯”姐姐？问号，问号？配上一张范妮的照片。
Correct. Gotta play that one. I'm sorry, but at the same time, I have to play this one. Another one so quickly? Yep. What does so quickly? Yep. What does it say? Bullsh-t nephew, question mark, question mark.
没错。得打出这张。对不起，但与此同时，我还得打出这一张。又来一张，这么快？对啊。这上面写的什么？“胡扯”外甥，问号，问号？
How in the hell in the world of Dwight, who loves family so much, would we not know that he had a brother, a sister, and a nephew? These are big bullsh-t cards. They are. They are. Well, we also had some bullsh-t cards from a fan mail flurry about Dwight's nephew,
在德怀特的世界里，他明明那么爱家人，怎么可能见鬼的不知道他还有一个哥哥、一个姐姐和一个外甥呢？这些都是重磅“胡扯”牌。确实是。没错。好吧，关于德怀特的外甥，我们还收到了一些来自粉丝来信狂潮的“胡扯”牌。
who was played by Blake Garrett Rosenthal, because, for example, Louise A. from Ireland pointed out, I have been waiting patiently to ask about this since the first time I ever watched The Office. Dwight's nephew in this episode is the same boy who appears in season 7, episode 9. Louise is with us because Luis pointed out this happens at nine minutes and 50 seconds when he pays Dwight three extra bucks to go on the hayride again. He's a kid at the hayride.
这个角色由布莱克·加勒特·罗森塔尔饰演，因为，比方说来自爱尔兰的露易丝·A指出：“自从我第一次看《办公室》以来，我一直耐心地等待着问这件事。这一集里德怀特的外甥，就是第七季第9集里出现的那个小男孩。”露易丝和我们心有灵犀，因为路易斯指出这一幕发生在第9分50秒，当时他多付给德怀特三块钱，想再坐一次稻草车。他就是那个坐稻草车的小孩。
And Dwight doesn't even like acknowledge him. It's his own nephew. Nick N from Minnesota pointed out that he also goes on to play the son of Matt Jones' character on the sitcom Mom. Matt Jones played Zeke, Dwight's other cousin. Okay. So this kid is working a lot. But I guess I should also do a guest star alert for Fanny Shroot, who was played by Mahondra Delfino. You probably recognize her as Maria from Roswell. She danced with the Miami Ballet from age 4 to 13,
而德怀特甚至都不理他。这可是他亲外甥啊。来自明尼苏达州的尼克·N指出，他后来还在情景喜剧《老妈》中扮演了马特·琼斯角色的儿子。马特·琼斯饰演了齐克，德怀特的另一个表弟。好吧。所以这小孩通告很多啊。不过我想我还是应该为扮演范妮·施鲁特的莫罕德拉·德尔菲诺做个客串演员提醒。你大概能认出她是《罗斯韦尔》里的玛丽亚。她从4岁到13岁曾在迈阿密芭蕾舞团跳舞，
and also studied classical piano. Wow. Very multi-talented. Yeah. Well, why don't we take a break? Yeah, let's take a break because when we come back, we're going to meet Dwight's new love interest. MUSIC We are back and Dwight's neighbor Henry pulls up in his pickup truck and it's just full
还学习过古典钢琴。哇。多才多艺。对啊。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下呢？对，我们休息一下吧，因为当我们回来时，我们将去见德怀特的新爱慕对象。音乐 我们回来了，德怀特的邻居亨利把他的皮卡车开了过来，车斗里
of ladies in the back. They're his daughters and one of them is Esther. Yeah, Henry was played by Tom Bauer. He's a long longtime character actor. He has appeared in Die Hard 2, Iron Eagle 3, Lucky Hank, Bosch, Grey's Anatomy, and Monk. Oh. And Nora Kirkpatrick plays Esther. She's so beautiful.
坐满了女士。她们是他的女儿们，其中一个就是埃丝特。对，亨利由汤姆·鲍尔饰演。他是一位资深性格演员。他曾出演过《虎胆龙威2》《鹰爪铁战士3》《幸运汉克》《博斯》《实习医生格蕾》和《神探阿蒙》。噢。诺拉·柯派屈克饰演埃丝特。她长得太漂亮了。
Oh, my gosh. She's so beautiful. She's so talented. Dwight is going to flirt with her. Fanny's like, hey, it's a funeral. Table that. Yeah. We got a ton of fan mail about Esther.
噢，天哪。她太漂亮了。她太有才华了。德怀特要去撩她了。范妮在一旁说，嘿，这可是葬礼。收敛点吧。对啊。我们收到了大量关于埃丝特的粉丝来信。
For example, from Lindsay P. in Fargo, North Dakota, who said, this is a Nora Kirkpatrick appreciation post. I love so much about her. I love that she was a member of Edward Sharp and the Magnetic Zeroes. I love that she was a member of Edward Sharpe and the Magnetic Zeroes. I love that she plays accordion in real life. And what I love most about her is what I love about you two, Mindy, and other awesome women out there. She's a creative.
比如来自北达科他州法戈的林赛·P，她说：“这是一篇诺拉·柯派屈克赞赏贴。我太喜欢她身上的很多特质了。我喜欢她是爱德华·夏普与磁性零点乐队（Edward Sharpe and the Magnetic Zeros）的成员。我喜欢她是爱德华·夏普与磁性零点乐队的成员。我喜欢她现实生活中会拉手风琴。而我最喜欢她的一点，也就是我喜欢你们两个、明迪以及其他所有优秀女性的一点：她是一个富有创造力的人。
In this case, a writer specifically. I am an aspiring television show writer myself, and I'd love to know everything about her, what it was like working with her, and more. Well, yes. Lindsay, Nora is crazy talented. She is an accomplished actress, writer, also a director, also a musician.
具体来说，在这个案子里她是个编剧。我自己就是一个有志成为电视编剧的人，我很想了解关于她的一切，比如跟她合作是什么感觉，等等。”好吧，是的。林赛，诺拉非常有才华。她是一位杰出的演员、作家，同时也是一位导演和音乐家。
In fact, she was the first woman to direct a campaign for Bud Light. I did not know that. Yeah, she's directed a bunch of commercials. She's also won a Grammy as a member of Edward Sharp and the Magnetic Zeroes. I really love this group. You probably recognize their song Home,
事实上，她是第一位执导百威淡啤广告大片的女性。我以前不知道这件事。对啊，她执导过一堆广告。她还作为爱德华·夏普与磁性零点乐队的成员获得过格莱美奖。我真的很喜欢这个乐队。你大概能听出他们的那首歌《Home》，
which was a huge hit. They were on all the talk shows. You wanna hear it? I've got an audio clip. Okay, so this is the song. It opens with all the whistling. Okay, here's the whistling. opens with all the whistling. Okay, here's the whistling.
那可是一首超级大热单曲。他们上过所有的脱口秀节目。你想听听吗？我有一段音频剪辑。好的，这就是那首歌。开场全是口哨声。好吧，听口哨声。开场全是口哨声。好吧，听口哨声。
["Wisting"] I remember the whistling. Yes. It just makes you happy right away. It really does. Then here's the chorus that you will remember as well. All right, so that song got stuck in my head for about three days after I pulled that clip. It's just so catchy. It's so catchy. Well, everyone, we reached out to Nora. We traded emails with her about her time on the show.
【口哨声】 我还记得这段口哨声。是的。它立刻就能让人心情愉悦。确实如此。接下来是副歌，你肯定也记得。好啦，自我截取这段音频后，这首歌就在我脑子里单曲循环了大约三天。太洗脑了。真的很洗脑。好吧，各位，我们联系了诺拉。我们通过邮件交流了她在剧组的时光。
Of course, we had to ask how she got her job on the office, and she said that she originally auditioned for Fanny, Dwight's sister. Oh. She said she remembers coming in a few times, and in one of the sessions, her and Rain improvised a bit about various family-related matters. But after the audition, she heard they were thinking of her for something else and was eventually told that she would be a potential love interest for Dwight on the farm. Yeah. Maybe they had a little bit too much chemistry.
当然，我们不得不问她是如何得到《办公室》这份工作的，她说她最初是为德怀特的姐姐范妮试镜的。噢。她说她记得来试镜过好几次，在其中一场试镜中，她和雷恩即兴发挥了一段关于各种家庭琐事的对话。但在试镜后，她听说他们正在考虑让她演别的角色，最后被告知她将成为德怀特在农场上的潜在爱慕对象。对啊。也许他们之间有点太有化学反应了。
Yeah. Noor also said she was a die-hard fan of The Office and getting cast was a dream come true. She also shared that it felt very fitting for it to be farm-related as she grew up in Iowa and her dad was at one time in his life a corn farmer. So she felt very at home with the storyline. I love that. I know. Aww. Well, back at the gravesite, Dwight shares that they've had some incidents of accidental
对啊。诺拉还说她是《办公室》的死忠粉，能被选上简直是梦想成真。她还分享说，这感觉跟农场非常契合，因为她是在爱荷华州长大的，她父亲在生前曾一度是个玉米农夫。所以她对这个故事线感到非常自在。我好喜欢这个。我知道。啊——哦。好吧，在墓地现场，德怀特分享说他们曾发生过一些意外活埋以及盗墓贼在棺材里发现抓痕的事件。所以出于善良，他们决定自己动手。
live burials and grave robbers found scratch marks inside the coffins. So now out of kindness, they take matters into their own hands. That's when the minister tosses him a shotgun to make sure Aunt Shirley really is dead. This is the breaking point for Oscar. He's like, I'm out. Yeah, Oscar's seen enough. Steve Burgess said that Rain had to do a test firing of the shotgun using blanks,
就在这时，牧师扔给他一把猎枪，好确保雪莉阿姨真的死透了。这是奥斯卡的崩溃点。他直接表态：我不干了。对，奥斯卡已经看够了。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说雷恩必须用空包弹对猎枪进行试射，
and he had to go through safety training. He said we had our stunt coordinator, Brett Jones, on set, and of course, Kelly, who he called the queen of safety meetings, held a giant safety meeting with the cast and crew before we shot that scene. Kelly Cantley. I love her safety meetings. This was a real safety meeting. This was a real before we shot that scene. Kelly Cantley.
而且他必须接受安全培训。他说我们的特技协调员布雷特·吉尔斯在片场，当然，凯利——他称之为安全会议女王——在我们拍摄那场戏之前，跟演员和剧组人员开了一场盛大的安全会议。凯利·坎特利。我太喜欢她的安全会议了。这可是一场真正的安全会议。这可是在我们拍摄那场戏之前的一场真正的安全会议。凯利·坎特利。
I love her safety meetings. This was a real safety meeting. This was a real deal one. This was not lit candle. This was not, we have three paper clips that have been taken apart. They are pointy. They are pointy.
我太喜欢她的安全会议了。这可是一场真正的安全会议。这是一场动真格的安全会议。这可不是点根蜡烛。这可不是，我们拿了三个拆开的回形针。它们很尖。它们很尖。
I think the most dangerous thing that we had on our set of anything we had was the Death Star. Of course it was. That giant, giant metal pronged star that hung from the ceiling in Morocco. So low. So low in Moroccan Christmas. Mm-hmm.
我觉得我们在片场拥有的最危险的东西，莫过于死星了。那当然了。那个挂在摩洛哥圣诞派对天花板上、带有巨大巨大金属尖端的星星。挂得太低了。在《摩洛哥圣诞》里挂得太低了。嗯哼。
Yeah. You know why? Because it was a sneaky danger. We didn't see that one coming. Sneaky danger, yeah. Sneaks up on you. You walk into it. Mm-hmm.
对啊。你知道为什么吗？因为它是个潜伏的危险。我们压根没料到那个。潜伏的危险，对。悄悄向你袭来。你会一头撞上去。嗯哼。
Okay, we are back in the conference room. Pam is really insisting to everyone that they cannot eat these cupcakes. Packer cannot buy their forgiveness. This is when we learned that Creed is really great with numbers. I mean, he forgets literally everything else, but he has a gift with numbers. And that's why he's an accountant, which he is not. That's right. None of us really know what Creed does,
好了，我们回到了会议室。帕姆极力向大家强调他们绝对不能吃这些纸杯蛋糕。帕克休想买下大家的宽恕。正是在这里我们得知克里德在数字方面真的很厉害。我的意思是，他 literalmente 忘掉了一切其他事情，但他对数字有着天赋。这就是为什么他是会计师，然而他并不是。没错。我们没人真正知道克里德到底是干什么的，
and clearly Creed does not either. Clark and Todd Packer, who are sitting out at the desks, they're not in the conference room, are going to have a moment. Todd's going to apologize to Clark for calling him a fat little runt. Clark tells Todd, you did not call me that. And Todd Packer says, well, I'm just in
显然克里德自己也不知道。坐在外面办公桌旁的克拉克和托德·帕克——他们不在会议室里——将迎来一个互动时刻。托德要为之前管克拉克叫“肥胖的小矮子”向他道歉。克拉克告诉托德：“你根本没这么叫过我。”托德·帕克却说：“好吧，我只是习惯了为我脑子里闪过的想法道歉。”他给了克拉克一个纸杯蛋糕。
the habit of apologizing for thoughts I had in my head. He gives Clark a cupcake. Stanley really wants to eat the cupcakes. He's really making a case for it. Yeah, he said, you know, we've done some stuff to Packer. Like we sent him to Florida on a prank. Nellie's like, that's true. And I fired him. They're all trying to justify eating these cupcakes. Well, people like cupcakes, Ange, and that's why I brought them in for your birthday. I know. I really want to have some. They're sitting right in front of me.
斯坦利真的很想吃纸杯蛋糕。他正在极力为之辩护。对啊，他说，你知道的，我们以前也对帕克做过不少事。比如我们搞了个恶作剧把他弄去了佛罗里达。奈莉说：“确实如此。”然后我把他解雇了。他们都在试图为吃这些纸杯蛋糕找借口。好吧，人们就是喜欢纸杯蛋糕，安吉拉，这就是为什么我为你过生日把它买来的。我知道。我真的很想吃几个。它们就摆在我面前。
Well, now would be a good time because I also asked you your favorite cupcake flavors for another reason, not just for your birthday. Does this say something about you, or am I now gonna find out that I'm just basic? Yes, you've ruined the surprise. I'm sorry. I found an article on spoonuniversity.com.
好吧，现在是个好时机，因为我出于另一个原因也问过你最喜欢的纸杯蛋糕口味是什么，不光是为了你的生日。这能说明你什么问题吗？还是说我现在会发现我其实只是个很俗气的人？没错，你把惊喜给剧透了。对不起。我在spoonuniversity.com上找到了一篇文章。
What does your favorite cupcake flavor say about you? Oh no. All right, are you ready? Angela, when I asked you what kind of cupcake you like, you said vanilla. And that means you are quote, the boring friend who doesn't know how to text. F*** you, spoonuniversity.com.
你最喜欢的纸杯蛋糕口味说明了你是个什么样的人？噢不。好吧，准备好了吗？安吉拉，当我问你喜欢什么口味的纸杯蛋糕时，你说是香草味。这意味着你，引用：“是个不懂怎么发短信的无聊朋友。”去你的，spoonuniversity.com。
But not wrong. I know how to text. What is wrong with my texting? And I am anything but boring. Well, this is true, but it goes on to say, unfortunately, Angela, you're unoriginal, but it's okay. What? It says it's okay.
但这倒也没说错。我知道怎么发短信。我的短信到底有什么毛病？而且我绝对算不上无聊。好吧，这倒也是，但文章接着说，不幸的是，安吉拉，你毫无新意，不过没关系。什么？上面说没关系。
We're all a little unoriginal and like to stick to the basics sometimes. If this is your classic cupcake order, you just like simplicity. I wish my life was as easy as this cupcake, is what you're saying. You crave simplicity, so you keep it simple with your cupcakes. I'm sorry, but unoriginal.
我们大家都有点毫无新意，有时就喜欢坚持最基础的东西。如果这是你的经典纸杯蛋糕点单，说明你只喜欢简单。我希望我的生活能像这个纸杯蛋糕一样简单，你这是这意思。你渴望简单，所以你的纸杯蛋糕也保持简单。对不起，但“毫无新意”——
Sounds like someone's throwing shade. I'm sorry, this is just what it said. Cassie, you said in your email that you do not love cupcakes, which is very on brand for you, but when forced to choose, you chose red velvet. This means that you are quote, the one who's going to grow up to be a surgeon.
听起来像是在暗讽别人。对不起，这上面就是这么写的。卡西，你在邮件里说你其实不太喜欢纸杯蛋糕，这非常符合你的性格，但当被迫做出选择时，你选了红丝绒。这意味着你，引用：“是个以后会长大当外科医生的人。”
What? What? It says- Spoon University is full of shit. Those two are so different. I know. It says, red velvet cupcakes mean business. You're slick and smooth and well dressed. That moist cupcake and cream cheese frosting mesh together so well, just like
什么？什么？上面写着—— Spoon University太扯淡了。这两者完全不搭边啊。我知道。上面写着：红丝绒纸杯蛋糕意味着动真格。你圆滑、流畅且衣着得体。那湿润的蛋糕和奶油奶酪糖霜完美融合，就像
your life seems to. Wait, can we, Cassie, will you just say what you're wearing today? Yeah, I'm wearing slides and basketball shorts. I am like the worst dressed one today. Not according to your cupcake. All right. Sam and I both chose chocolate with vanilla frosting. Sam, you and I are quote, the fake hipster. Okay, damn. Spoon University hates all of us. Who runs this site?
你的人生看起来的那样。等等，卡西，你能说一下你今天穿的是什么吗？好吧，我穿着凉拖和篮球短裤。我今天绝对是穿得最土的一个。这可跟你的纸杯蛋糕说的不一样。好吧。萨姆和我选的都是巧克力配香草糖霜。萨姆，你和我，引用：“是个伪文青。”好吧，该死。Spoon University恨死我们所有人了。谁运营这个网站的？
Okay. Jenna, do you run Spoon? I do not. I do not. But runs this site? Okay. Jenna, do you run Spoon? No, I do not. I do not. But here's what it says. It says, if a chocolate cupcake with vanilla frosting is a regular in your diet, you're probably pretty basic too.
好吧。珍娜，Spoon是你在运营吗？我才没有。我没有。但谁运营这个网站的？好吧。珍娜，Spoon是你在运营吗？不是，我才没有。我没有。但上面是这么说的：
Jesus. You just get the chocolate cupcake to pretend you're more edgy. Who hurt this person? I don't know. I think whoever wrote this doesn't like anyone. Yeah. Yeah. All right, now Sam, in your email,
如果巧克力配香草糖霜的纸杯蛋糕是你的日常标配，那你大概也是个挺俗气的人。天哪。你买巧克力纸杯蛋糕纯粹是为了假装自己更有先锋个性。到底是哪个混蛋受过这网站的伤害？我不知道。我觉得写这篇东西的人谁也不喜欢。对啊。对啊。好吧，萨姆，在你的邮件里，
you were trying to decide between chocolate with vanilla frosting and Oreo. Yeah, that's right. Angela, is there any chance you would go Oreo? No. Okay, Oreo, Oreo is quote, the one who writes in a diary. Okay.
你当时在巧克力配香草糖霜和奥利奥之间纠结。对，没错。安吉拉，你有一点点可能会选奥利奥吗？完全不会。好吧，奥利奥，奥利奥，引用：“是那种会写日记的人。”好吧。
Oh Sam, how's your diary? Honestly, good. Well, here's, if you choose Oreo, it says you're a bit of a piece of work from the outside, you're sweet. I mean, who wouldn't be, but once people dig deep enough, they'll find out you've got some very profound secrets. Are any of these good? Yeah.
哦萨姆，你的日记写得怎么样？说实话，还挺好的。好吧，上面写着：如果你选了奥利奥，说明你表面上看起来是个挺难搞的人，你人其实很好——废话，谁不是呢——但只要别人深入了解，就会发现你藏着一些非常深奥的秘密。这些里面有哪个是好的吗？有啊。
Well, I'll tell you what. I'll tell you what, I'm gonna end with this one because. Is it lemon? Cause I also love lemon. It's lemon! Oh, that was the one I didn't say that one cause I love lemon. Oh no, oh no.
好吧，我跟你讲。我跟你讲，我要以这个做结，因为—— 是柠檬味吗？因为我也很喜欢柠檬味。是柠檬味！噢，这就是我刚才没说的那款，因为我太爱柠檬味了。噢不，噢不。
I almost picked lemon. If the bakery where I got our cupcakes would have had lemon, I would have gotten lemon. I love lemon. But it didn't, so I had to go with the chocolate with vanilla frosting. Yeah, vanilla's like, I'll take vanilla, but if there's lemon, I'll almost always pick it,
我差点就选柠檬味了。如果买我们纸杯蛋糕的那家烘焙店有柠檬味的话，我肯定买柠檬味了。我超爱柠檬味。但它没有，所以我只能选巧克力配香草糖霜。对啊，香草味就属于，行吧我选香草，但如果有柠檬味，我几乎总是会选柠檬味，
but there's usually not. Okay, well. Uh-oh. Lemon is, quote, the one who hates 90% of the friend group, but pretends to love all of them. Jesus. This is like, this is a hilarious like take on cupcakes. Someone was dumped by a cupcake,
不过通常没有。好吧，那—— 噢不。柠檬味，引用：“是那种讨厌90%的朋友圈子、但又假装爱他们所有人的那种人。”天哪。这简直就像是——对纸杯蛋糕的一种极其搞笑的解读。写这篇的人是被纸杯蛋糕甩过吧，
or someone was broken up with by a cupcake. Here's what it says, if you're eating a lemon cupcake, it says you've got an attitude no one can quite understand. Everyone loves you, but you're a little bit less sweet and loving than everyone else is. It's okay. Sometimes it's hard to love crazy bitches. Whoa.
或者被一个纸杯蛋糕给甩了。上面是这么写的：如果你在吃柠檬蛋糕，说明你有一种让人完全无法理解的态度。每个人都爱你，但你比其他任何人都稍微不那么甜美、不那么有爱心一点。没关系。有时候要爱一个疯狂的碧池真的很难。哇。
So what am I? Am I unoriginal or am I a crazy bitch? Maybe a little of both. I'm a like, I'm a column B. Yeah. Well, there you have it. That's what your cupcake choice says about you. Spoon University is a harsh place.
那我到底算什么？我是毫无新意还是个疯狂的碧池？也许两样有点沾边吧。我觉得我是……B类吧。好吧，事实就是如此。这就是你的纸杯蛋糕选择对你的定义。Spoon University是个残酷的地方。
Damn. Can I have my cupcake now? Sure. Dig in everybody. Well, lady, I will say you and I both love lemon cupcakes. So what does that say? I guess we're a couple of crazy bitches. I guess so.
该死。我现在能吃我的纸杯蛋糕了吗？当然可以。大家开动吧。好吧，女士，我得说你和我都很爱柠檬味纸杯蛋糕。那这说明了什么？我猜我们俩就是一对疯狂的碧池吧。我猜是吧。
All right, well now we're gonna go back to Aunt Shirley's house. Her family has gathered to watch a farewell video. It's like her will. Yes, I wrote this. I did not play a bullsh** card here, but I would like to say that this video lays a lot of pipe. Well, we also had to reshoot this video.
好啦，现在我们要回到雪莉阿姨的家里。她的家人聚在一起观看一份遗嘱视频。这就像是她的遗嘱一样。是的，这段是我写的。我这里没出示“胡扯”牌，但我必须得说，这段视频铺垫了相当多的背景。好吧，我们还得重拍这个视频。
We mentioned this during moving on. There was originally a different woman cast as Aunt Shirley in the pilot of the farm. And this was the only thing that that actress had to do was just read this will. But when they wrote moving on and they expanded the role, they cast just legendary character actress, Mary Gillis in the role.
我们在聊“继续前行”那一集时提到过这件事。最初在《农场》试播集里，饰演雪莉阿姨的是另一位女演员。那位女演员唯一要做的就是宣读这份遗嘱。但当他们写了“继续前行”并扩充了这个角色时，他们请来了传奇性格演员玛丽·吉利斯来演这个角色。
Well, this video sets up the whole entire series, if it would have gone. Listen to this. Aunt Shirley on the video says, Thank you for coming to my funeral. As I gaze at life's big sunset, I can't help but wonder where it all went wrong. You've all disappointed me greatly. Fanny, a single mama in the city. Jeb, a street pusher.
好吧，这段视频为整个衍生剧系列（如果它能拍成的话）设定好了全部基调。听听这个。雪莉阿姨在视频里说：“感谢你们来参加我的葬礼。当我凝视着生命壮丽的日落时，我不禁在想，这一切到底是从哪开始出错的。你们所有人都太让我失望了。范妮，一个在城市里的单亲妈妈；杰布，一个街头小贩。”
And so we find out that Jeb has a nine acre worm farm, which turns out worm means marijuana. And then Aunt Shirley ends it with, we can't just sit by and watch our family farm disappear. So here are my terms. Dwight, Fanny and Jeb, if you come back home, I will leave you my farm. So there, you have it. So in this my terms, Dwight, Fanny and Jeb, if you come back home, I will leave you my farm. So there, you have it.
于是我们发现，杰布其实有一个九英亩的“虫子农场”，结果证明这“虫子”指的是大麻。雪莉阿姨最后总结道：“我们不能只是坐视不管，看着我们的家族农场消失。所以这是我的条件：德怀特、范妮和杰布，如果你们回家，我就把农场留给你们。所以，情况就是这样。”所以在这个——这是我的条件：德怀特、范妮和杰布，如果你们回家，我就把农场留给你们。所以，情况就是这样。
So in this one video, we learn what the whole entire premise of the series is gonna be. Yes, we also learned earlier that Aunt Shirley's farm is, I guess, adjacent to Dwight's farm. So they would have Dwight's farm and this farm and they'd have all that land. We now have two talking heads, Jeb has a talking head and then Dwight's farm and this farm and they'd have all that land. We now have two talking heads, Jeb has a talking head and then Dwight.
所以在这一段视频里，我们知道了整部剧集的全部前提将会是什么。是的，我们之前也了解到，雪莉阿姨的农场，我猜，就在德怀特农场的旁边。所以他们会拥有德怀特的农场和这个农场，他们将拥有所有这些土地。我们现在有了两个单人采访（talking head），杰布有一个单人采访，然后——德怀特的农场和这个农场，他们将拥有所有这些土地。我们现在有了两个单人采访，杰布有一个单人采访，然后德怀特。
There are two talking head locations on the farm. You're either in the porch swing or you're in the rocking chair on the porch. Oh, nice catch. If you watch the talking heads in the rocking chair, Dwight has one and Zeke has one later, you will see a blue Weber grill in the background. Oh. Isn't that so random? Like a Weber grill, you know, a blue Weber grill in the background. Oh.
农场里有两个单人采访的取景地。你要么坐在门廊秋千上，要么坐在门廊的摇椅上。噢，好细心的发现。如果你注意看坐在摇椅上的单人采访——德怀特有一个，后来齐克也有一个——你会看到背景里有一个蓝色的韦伯烤炉（Weber grill）。噢。
Isn't that so random? Like a Weber grill, you know, with the lid that you lift up? Yeah. Yeah. Just there. Are you feeling like Aunt Shirley wouldn't have had a Weber grill? I don't know. It just seems like such random placement.
这不是很随机吗？就像一个韦伯烤炉，你知道的，带有可以掀开的盖子的那种？对啊。对啊。就摆在那。你是不是觉得雪莉阿姨根本不会有一个韦伯烤炉？我不知道。这看起来摆放得太随机了。
Hmm. I wonder if there was like a little Weber grill deal or something. It's not on a porch. It's not anywhere where it looks like you would use it. It's just tucked on the side of the wall of like a shed. grill deal or something. It's not on a porch. It's not anywhere where it looks like you would use it. It's just tucked on the side of the wall of like a shed. I don't know. Every time I watched The Talking Heads,
嗯。我在想这里面是不是有什么小小的韦伯烤炉赞助协议之类的。它不在门廊上。它不在任何看起来你会使用它的地方。它只是被塞在一个类似棚屋的墙壁旁边。烤炉赞助协议之类的。它不在门廊上。它不在任何看起来你会使用它的地方。它只是被塞在一个类似棚屋的墙壁旁边。我不知道。每次我看单人采访时，
all I could think about was the Weber grill. The Weber grill is really near and dear to my heart. My dad grills on a Weber grill. My dad had one for years. Well, this is, I think now clear why you spotted it. Maybe so. I missed it. Well, Dwight is gonna tell Fanny and Jeb,
我满脑子想的都是那个韦伯烤炉。韦伯烤炉在我心里有着特殊而深厚的情感。我爸爸就用韦伯烤炉烧烤。我爸爸以前有一个用好多年。好吧，我想现在很清楚为什么你能一眼看到了。也许吧。我倒没注意到。好吧，德怀特打算对范妮和杰布说，
you know what, we should do this. We should. And Fanny's like, I'm sorry, Dwight, but a farmwife lacks the sophistication that she's used to. Yeah, she says there's a sort of willing ignorance to the men. And then she has a talking head. She's on the porch swing.
你知道吗，我们真该这么做。我们应该这么做。范妮却说，对不起，德怀特，但农场主妇可没有她习惯的那种精致感。对啊，她说那些男人有一种刻意装出的无知。然后她做了一个单人采访。她坐在门廊秋千上。
It was very funny to me, cause she's like, I have written some poetry, thanks for asking. I actually had a poem recently published. Oh, do I have it? Yes, I do. Here it is. It's from the Hartford Women's Lit Quarterly.com and it is titled, A Willing Ignorance by Fanny Shroot.
这把我逗乐了，因为她说：“我写过一些诗，谢谢你的关心。我最近实际上有一首诗发表了。”噢，我有吗？没错，我确实有。在这呢。它出自《哈特福德女性文学季刊网》（Hartford Women's Lit Quarterly.com），题目是《刻意装出的无知》，作者范妮·施鲁特。
Lady, I paused on it and I tried to, what do you call that, make it bigger? Yes. I took a picture. Same. I looked. Same. I really wanted to read her poem.
女士，我当时暂停了视频，然后试着去——你们管那叫什么来着——放大？对。我拍了张照片。我也是。我看过。我也是。我真的很想读读她的诗。
I really did too. And so I went to the writer's notes for this episode and I found it. You did not. I did. We're gonna hear Fanny's poem right now? We sure are. Okay, I can't wait. Here it is, A Willing Ignorance by Fanny's poem right now? We sure are! Okay, I can't wait.
我其实也特别想。所以我去找了这一集的编剧笔记，然后我找到了。你才没有。我真的找到了。我们现在就能听到范妮的诗了吗？当然可以。好的，我等不及了。在这呢，《刻意装出的无知》，作者——我们现在就能听到范妮的诗了吗？当然可以！好的，我等不及了。
Here it is, A Willing Ignorance by Fanny Schrute. The men I meet are nearly completely ignorant of all things worthwhile. Whether current events or the classics, these gents think well-read is a lipstick shade for a lady's smile. Their libraries consist of the Bible, of course, but it doesn't avert them from sin. The only way I'd describe them as holy is if they flashed me their toothless grin. The men I meet are so patriotic, their minds are like the national debt. But if what they say about ignorance is true, they are as blissful as one can get.
在这里：《刻意装出的无知》，作者范妮·施鲁特。我遇到的男人，对所有有价值的事物几乎都一无所知。无论是时事还是经典，这群绅士觉得“博学”不过是女士微笑时涂的口红代号。他们的藏书自然只有《圣经》，但这并不能阻止他们作恶。唯一能让我觉得他们“圣洁”的时刻，只有当他们向我露出无齿的狞笑。我遇到的男人是如此爱国，他们的脑子简直就像国债一样深不可测。但如果他们对无知的看法没错的话，那他们可真是人间至乐、傻人有傻福了。
Wow. Fanny was holding onto it a lot. This does not sound like a woman who's gonna wanna come back to this farm. Does not. Well, listen, Jeb also doesn't wanna come back to the farm. He says people here are like a fart, which I guess is another way to put it. Then he makes a fart noise
哇。范妮把这首诗憋在心里很久了啊。这听起来可不像是一个想回这个农场的人。确实不像。好吧，听着，杰布也不想回农场。他说这里的人就像个屁，我猜这是另一种表达方式。然后他学了个放屁的声音，
in case you're not sure what a fart is. Dwight says, you know what? Why don't you guys stay for a few nights and then decide. Zeke is in. Zeke is like, I'll do it. He has a talking head where he said, you know, it really wasn't easy growing up with Dwight and Moe's because Dwight
以防你不确定屁是什么样的。德怀特说：“你知道吗？要不你们俩在这儿多住几个晚上再决定吧。”齐克倒是挺乐意。齐克做了一个单人采访，在采访里他说：“你知道的，在德怀特和莫斯手下长大真的一点都不容易，因为德怀特
is obviously the cool one and Moe's was the visionary. And that left him to be the comedian. 13 minutes, 21 seconds, blue Weber grill. There it is. There it is. Somehow Dwight is going to charm Fanny into agreeing to stay a few days. By counting incorrectly in French. Yeah. Yeah. But they have a laugh,
显然是那个酷炫的人，而莫斯是个有远见的人。这导致他只能当个喜剧演员。”第13分钟21秒，蓝色的韦伯烤炉。它就在那。它就在那。德怀特不知怎么用法语数错了数，就把范妮给迷住了，让她同意留几天。用法语数数数错了。对啊。但他们在沙发上笑作一团，有点像兄妹之间的打闹，然后她说：“好吧，好吧。”对啊。好吧，女士，你知道我跟你说过我从我的数码杂物箱里找出了几样东西吧。对啊。我已经分享了两个了。这是我的最后一个。好的。
like a little wrestle sibling thing on the couch, and she's like, okay, fine. Yeah. Well, lady, you know I told you I had a few things from my digital clutter. Yeah. I've shared two. Here's my last one. Okay.
我们都知道你和我当时正试图弄清楚我们要怎么利用这段假期。对啊。我正试着和伊莎贝尔去德克萨斯州。没错。然后你给我发了封邮件，内容是这样的：
We know that you and I were trying to figure out what we were gonna do with this time off. Yeah. I'm trying to get to Texas with Isabel. Yep. And I got there. Oh, nice. And you emailed me, here's what I'm doing.
你发了什么？你的邮件标题叫《慢悠悠地瞎晃荡》（Puttering）。你说：“今天是美式橄榄球梦幻联赛日。我们俩都穿着球衣，正一块儿闲晃呢。我们刚把门边的篮子清理干净。我简直置身天堂。”附件是一张超级可爱的照片，照片里你和你婴儿期的儿子穿着亲子球衣，正对视着大笑。
What did I do? You titled the email, puttering. And you said, today is fantasy football day. We are both in our jerseys and we are puttering together. We just cleaned out the basket by the door. I'm in heaven. And attached was the cutest photo of you and your baby son in matching jerseys looking at each other and laughing.
啊—— 我回信说：“我爱这张照片的一切。我有这张照片。你想看吗？什么？你想看？噢，我要哭了。我知道。这太甜了，女士。
Aww. And I wrote back and said, I love everything about this photo. And I have it. You want to see it? What? You do? Oh, I'm going to cry. I know. It is the sweetest thing, lady.
你当时笑得好开心。好吧，这小孩马上就要13岁了，所以。噢，这简直要催生泪腺了。准备好了吗？让我看看。这也太珍贵了。别闹了。对啊。
You were so happy. Well, this kid's about to turn 13, so. Oh, this is just going to cue the waterworks. Ready? Let me see. This is precious. Stop it now. Yep.
噢，天哪。好吧。你知道我通常不怎么分享玛基托（Makito，宠物名/昵称）的照片。我知道。但你可以把这张发到《办公室女士》的播客账号上。我会把它发到快拍里。这就是你在《农场》放假期间过的一天。噢，我太喜欢这种慢悠悠瞎晃荡的日子了。我知道。所以各位，有时候多年不清理电子邮箱收件箱还真是一件好事。
Oh my gosh. All right. You know I don't often share pictures of Makitos. I know. But you can put this one on Office Ladies' pod. I'll put it in stories. That's what you were doing with your day off during the farm. Oh, I love to putter. I know. So sometimes, folks, it's a good thing that you don't clean out your email inbox for years.
我太感激你没有清理电子邮箱收件箱了。现在我们回到了后门廊。埃丝特、齐克和其他人正在演奏荒凉乐队（The Decemberists）的歌曲《Sons and Daughters》。我们收到了来自北爱尔兰贝尔法斯特的格蕾丝·F的粉丝提问，她说：“请告诉我关于荒凉乐队的《Sons and Daughters》这首歌是怎么被选中的所有细节。我真的超级喜欢这首歌，经常在YouTube上听。我觉得德怀特和他的家人在台阶上表演的这个版本简直完美。唯一遗憾的是它不够长。”好吧，格蕾丝，这首歌其实在最初的剧本里就有。这是保罗的主意。他超爱这首歌。说来也巧，雷恩·威尔逊认识科林·莫洛伊（Colin Meloy），
I am so grateful you don't clean out your email inbox. So now we are on the back porch. Esther, Zeke, and others are performing the song Sons and Daughters by the Decemberists. We had a fan question from Grace F. in Belfast, Northern Ireland who said, Please tell me everything about how the song Sons and Daughters by the Decemberists came to be picked. I absolutely love this and often listen to it on YouTube. I think the rendition that Dwight and his family do on the steps is just perfect. It's just a pity that it doesn't go on longer." Well, Grace, this song was in the original script. It was Paul's idea. He loves this song. And crazy enough, Rainn Wilson knew Colin Malloy
因为他们曾一起为科林写的一本书拍过宣传视频，两人因此成了朋友。我为此给雷恩发了短信，他实际上说科林是“异母同胞的好兄弟”。他问科林我们是否能在剧里使用这首歌。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说这花了一万五千美元，我想也许大家会想听听看。女士，我也很喜欢，我也想放给大家听。好吧，开始吧！当我们抵达时，儿子和女儿们，我们将建立我们的家园
from having done a promotional video for a book that Colin wrote, and they had become friends. I texted Rainn about this, and he actually said Colin is, quote, my brother from another mother. He asked Colin if we could use the song on the show. Steve Burgess said it cost $15,000, and I thought maybe we'd like to hear. Lady, I loved it too and I also wanted to play it. All right, here it is! When we arrive, sons and daughters, we'll make our homes
因为曾为科林写的一部书制作过宣传视频，两人因此成为了朋友。我把这件事发短信告诉了雷恩，他实际上说科林是“异母同胞的兄弟”。他问科林我们是否可以在节目中使用这首歌。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说这要花1.5万美元，我想也许我们会想听听。女士，我也很喜欢它，我也想播它。好了，它来了！当我们到达时，儿子和女儿们，我们将建立我们的家园
On the water, we'll build our walls for luminous We'll fill our mouths with cinnamon now We'll fill our mouths with luminous I'm a human being, I'm a human being. I'm a human being, I'm a human being. Well, I have to say this, Paul Lieberstein has really good taste in music. He does. Because I'm definitely liking the musicality of this pilot. The soundtrack.
Yes, exactly. Well, you guys all saw Nora playing the accordion in the scene and she plays the accordion in real life. We mentioned that earlier. And we asked her about playing it in this episode. She said it was a very last minute addition. She said Paul only realized that she was in Edward Sharpe and the Magnetic Zeroes and that she played accordion the night before they shot this scene.
He called her up and asked her if she would play a song with some of the other farm cast mates. She also said she'd been playing music with Matt Jones for years already. So it's just a real joy to work out the song in their trailers before they shot. She said she remembers going back and forth with him about which key to do it in. One was better for her, one was better for him, and she said he won. That's very funny. I think they sound fantastic.
I do too. I think we should hear them sing it at the end. Oh yes, I love that idea. Well, as this jam session continues, Dwight is gonna lay two little black things in front of Esther. Fanny notices this and she says, Oh yes, I forgot about this old custom. If a man wants to court
a woman, he'll throw the beaks of a crow at her and if she's interested, she must destroy the beaks. Yes. I would like to point out that during all of this sort of front porch time, Dwight looks like an Eddie Bauer catalog model. Did you think so? I did think so. In fact, during his talking head at 13 minutes 58 seconds, he has on a flannel shirt a sort of like a fashion puffer vest. This isn't like a puffer vest that is like one you would work in. It's like a fashion puffer vest. And his hair is especially shellacked. I love your distinction of the work puffer vest and the fashion puffer vest and his hair is especially shellacked. I love your distinction of the work puffer vest and the fashion puffer vest.
This is a fashion puffer vest. Okay. And also his hair. Did you see his hair? No. Like he got spiffy for this porch sing-along. Oh well maybe because he knew he was gonna present the beaks. Oh yeah. By the way, Esther does crush the beaks. So that means it's on. It is on. You know, this scene was originally the tag for the farm. And they moved it up. So this scene was going to originally end the farm. And either way, though, even though they decided not to pick up the farm,
they did like this idea of having this new romantic story for Dwight. They thought, oh, this is going to up the stakes for Dwight and Angela. So we are going to see more of Nora Kirkpatrick in some upcoming episodes. We sure are. We also asked Nora if she ever gets recognized for the role. And she said she does sometimes in very certain circles and it's always a joy. She said being on the show feels like a lifetime ago, but she's proud to be even the smallest part
of such an incredible show. She added that you can tell how happy the show makes people by the look in their eyes when they come over to say hello. That is so true. Yeah, it is. You know, I got curious. I don't know why. I mean, I should have known. This is not a real maiden custom.
Did you look up the crow beak? I did, and it kind known this is not a real mating custom. Did you look up the crow beak? I did, and it kind of led me down a road. I bet it did. I couldn't find any evidence of this being real. But I did get into mating customs, particularly within animals. Jenna. And... Jenna, what?
Jenna, you, what, your search history. I know. Are you going to share some? I'm going to share one. Because most of them, if you've watched any nature documentary, is to be expected, you know, spiders that do funny dances for each other. Sure, sure, sure. Birds that like fan out their feathers.
Yes, exactly. There was this one bird that builds elaborate like structures out of like sculptures almost out of twigs and things they find. I found a picture. It was really interesting. But the one that really was I'm going to say most interesting was the giraffe. Don't they whack their necks around or something? was the giraffe. Don't they whack their necks around or something? Well, I don't know about that, but a male giraffe tastes the urine of the female giraffe before mating.
They, like, nudge her, and then she pees in their mouth. Stop it. And they do this so they can tell if certain pheromones are present signaling that she is fertile before mating. But get this. There's more? On average, a male giraffe has to approach 150 females before finding one that is ready to mate. They just have to drink piss, like, for weeks.
150 different times. They're piss like for weeks. 150 different times. They're drinking pee for weeks. Yeah. A little tinkle. I'm going to say this with love. What is it? Stop Googling. I don't need to hear about that.
I don't need to have a visual of how this happens in my brain now. There are going to be times when I need you to put the Google down. Put it down. I mean, it was, I don't know. You had to share it. Yeah. It sat with you and you needed someone else to experience this moment with you. I mean, yeah.
I mean, okay. Well. At first I was like, oh, that's weird. But then I was like 150. No, let that hit you. Yeah. It's a lot of tinkles. Maybe they also whip their necks around. I don't know. I don't know if they do.
I don't know if they do. Oh my Lord. Well, back at Dunder Mifflin, Packer leaves and Kevin is really struggling not to eat his cupcake. Angela and Pam are trying to distract him. 15 minutes 35 seconds Pam and Angela are on the same team. Wow. This never happens. It has to be pointed out. We're gonna cut to Todd Packer in the parking lot and he says, yeah I'm going through a 12-step program. I'm currently on step zero. Have a bleep load of fun.
He said he actually spent six hours very carefully removing the frosting from every cupcake and then layering in a variety of drugs, some legal, some not. And he says you don't fire the Pac-Man and expect to get away with it. Wow. So now these cupcakes, if you eat them,
what will happen? We don't know. Nothing good. Right. Well, Pam is really proud of everyone they did it. No one's eating their cupcakes. Well. Well.
One person is. Brian Baumgartner should win an Emmy just for this moment. Oh, you're not the only person who thinks so. I literally thought he was choking and I was there and I knew he wasn't. Well, Christopher T. from Louisville, Kentucky, says, one of the things I love most about this podcast is hearing about everyone's singular favorite moment
of the office, and we finally reached mine. When Kevin chokes on his cupcake, I feel it in my soul. The nasal noises, the facial expressions, the struggling to swallow. This is the most perfect scene in all of cinema. And I couldn't remember. Well, he was not choking.
This was scripted, this choking bit. It was completely scripted. I went to the reshoots shooting draft, and here's how it was described. Kevin makes a grunting sound, and we pan over. He hits his desk. He is choking. Andy says, my God, he's choking.
Meredith goes over to hit him on the back and Kevin blocks her hand. He motions, uh-uh. Then with great effort, he swallows and he says, fantastic. Kevin then gasps for air. Pam shakes her head. Incredible, incredible interpretation of that moment. Brian Baumgartner. I mean, when I watched it, I like panicked for him. Yeah, I legitimately thought he had started choking and we went with it.
Some good acting, Brian. Also good acting from Kate when she comes over, because I felt like we were really concerned for him. Yeah. Wow. Well, we also had a fan catch from Becca G in Morgansfield, Kentucky, who said, I think that when Kevin is choking, I can see his mic in his tie.
Oh, yeah? Guess what, Becca, you're right. Did you screen grab it? 16 minutes what, Becca, you're right. Did you screen grab it? 16 minutes, 51 seconds. You can see his mic inside his little tie knot. That's where they would put the guy's mics. That's right.
Dwight is now gonna take his little nephew, who we never knew existed. Yes, Cameron. Cameron, to the chicken coop. They're gonna gather eggs, and he's teaching them how to milk a goat. It's a very sort of sweet moment between uncle and nephew.
Yes, Steve Burgess says he remembered that the snake wrangler found many snakes in the barn. Oh gosh. Where they shot this scene. I thought it really looked like Rain was milking this goat. I don't know. I was very impressed. If you watch his hands on the teat,
he's doing a really great job and you can hear it going in the bucket. It's like, pching, pching, pching. Yeah, I heard that. I figured they just added it in, but Rain would probably know how because he has farm animals. Well, I asked Steve Burgess
and he said Rain really milked the goat. That they had wranglers there to help him learn. He said he does think that the sound was enhanced in post. I reached out to Rain and he said he doesn't remember. Rain. I know. How can you not remember milking a goat, Rain? He said his memory is mush.
I also found out from Steve Burgess that all the animals How can you not remember milking a goat, Ray? He said his memory is mush. I also found out from Steve Burgess that all the animals and wranglers came through Bob Dunn. We had special wranglers for the goats and we had other wranglers for the chickens. The total for the animals, the wranglers was about $20,000. It was a lot of animals and wranglers, Steve said. Well, we learned an important piece of information in this scene.
Cam is going to share that he doesn't know many of these things because he's never met his dad. And this is setting up why Fanny is going to eventually agree to stay at this farm with her son. It's because she's going to see this bond. And you would have seen more of that in the pilot. to stay at this farm with her son is because she's gonna see this bond. And you would have seen more of that in the pilot. You would have seen her seeing it. You would have seen more of a need for it. And we had to like kind of crunch it all into this one scene.
Well, now it's the next day. And a very chipper Pam arrives to the office, but everyone seems like they are wrecked. Like really hung over. I really liked that Pam said that she thought it over. But everyone seems like they are wrecked. Yeah. Like really hung over. I really like that Pam said that she's thought it over. She talked to Jim and her sister and she's going to eat her cupcake now.
So much deliberation. This is you in real life. That's why it was amusing to me. Yeah. You would have to talk to three people before you could say, okay, I'm gonna eat that cupcake. Yeah, I would probably talk to you, my sister, and Lee. Yes.
And then I might Google some stuff. You would. And then you would make your decision. And I'd feel very good about my decision. Well, Phyllis just wants Pam to stop making noise, and Clark tells Pam that Packer laced the cupcakes. Some people got stoned, some people got diarrhea. Angela says, some people got both.
We learned that Phyllis played with her old dolls Some people got stoned, some people got diarrhea. Angela says, some people got both. Mm-hmm. We learned that Phyllis played with her old dolls on the floor and then ordered 10 American Girl doll outfits online. Thousands of dollars. Yes. Nellie and Stanley got the toilet. Clark went Christmas caroling in March.
And he fertilized some bushes along the way. And then Phyllis says, Andy, what did you do? Well, Andy and Kevin look at each other. They say they don't remember, but we've got some footage of them at Dunder Mifflin having a night. They had quite the night. I was very curious.
Was that montage, was that scripted or was that improvised? Well, here's what I found in the shooting draft. It says a series of quick cuts flashback to last night. On their way out, Andy and Kevin realized there are six leftover cupcakes in one of the boxes. They look at each other. They eat all six. Oh boy.
After eating all of them, they look at each other with satisfied faces, and then we see the first signs of the drugs kicking in. Kevin's smile gets weird, and Andy tries to figure out what's going on in his stomach. In the next scene, Andy and Kevin are arm wrestling. In the next scene, Kevin dances around the room while Andy DJs at a computer. The music we hear is Let Her Cry by Hootie and the Blowfish. Then in the conference room, Andy and Kevin sit cross-legged on the conference room table
touching each other's faces. Next scene, Kevin and Andy trade clothes. Next scene is in the men's restroom. Kevin and Andy sit side by side in the bathroom stalls. We just see their feet. Andy says, I cannot believe what is coming out of me. It's beautiful. Kevin says, you're beautiful. Andy says, life is beautiful. Kevin says, it really is. Cut back to present day. So not all of that made it
in, but quite a bit of it did. But it was scripted. Pam is like, this confirms that Todd Packer is the worst person. She's throwing her cupcake away, but Kevin eats it. I know. He eats another one of these laced cupcakes. Come on, Kevin. And then over in Philly, Todd Packer is doing
his whole spiel to Daryl and Jim, he gives them each a cupcake. Talk about someone who wants revenge. No one was gonna get skipped, even if he had to drive to a whole other town. I know, Packer can drive all the way to Philly just to give Jim and Daryl a cupcake, but Jim can't drive home to have dinner with his family. Cause it's too far.
Oh no. Well, now we're gonna have the final scene of the farm. Mm-oh. Because it's too far. Oh, no. Well, now we're going to have the final scene of the farm. Mm-hmm. This is where Fanny is going to decide to stay. Yeah. She sees this handshake, this bond that has started between Dwight and Cameron, and she's like, you know what? I need to stay.
Bullsh-t card number five is out, folks. Here it is. This is my final bullsh-t card. This might be a bit nitpicky, folks. Here it is. This is my final bullsh** card. This might be a bit nitpicky, I'm gonna admit. I don't know why I couldn't let this one go, lady. Here it is. Bullsh**. Overalls, question mark?
Please, please, look at Dwight's overalls in this scene when he's standing next to Fanny's car. These have never been worn before. Not for a hot second. These are brand new, shiny denim, stiff overalls. They have never seen a day's work on the farm. This is my overalls bulls**t card. Played like a true farm girl.
Thank you. Just get a pair of old overalls already. Well, guess what? Dwight, Fanny, and Jeb, they're standing together. They're looking at their new farm. It's going to take a lot of work to man this land, but they're up for it. Dwight says, I'll do it. Mm-hmm. Yep.
And that's the end of the episode. A big thank you to Steve Burges, Rainn Wilson, and of course, Nora Kirkpatrick. Everyone, Nora just made her first feature that she wrote and directed, starring Alexandra Daddario, Josh Gad, David Diggs, and Ashley Park. That should be coming out soon, she says.
It's called A Tree Fell in the Woods. And she just finished writing on a new show for Amazon called The Runaround. It'll be out early next year. It's about a young rock band. She fell in the woods and she just finished writing on a new show for Amazon called The Runaround. It'll be out early next year. It's about a young rock band and she said she thinks the show is going to be very special. You know, she was one of the writers of the show Daisy Jones and the Six. She's so talented.
I know. Nora, thank you so much. Yes, Nora, thank you so much. And thank you guys for sending in your questions and your comments. We love doing this comments. We love doing this podcast. We're so thrilled that Sam and Cassie are back. Sam, any words before we sign off? Yes, I do. One, Angela, you have to stop saying laying pipe. That's not what that means.
It is what it means, Sam. It's a writer's term. No, it's not. It is. It's both. We looked it up, Sam. We had to look it up, Sam. Because I said the same thing, and we did look it up, and it is something that writers use for script. We did Google it. But it does also mean something else. Thank you, Sam, for reminding us. Don't Google it, everybody.
Yes. I just wanted to give a massive thanks to the fans of the show who reached out with support when I was laid off. It got back to me the amount of support you sent and it really, really meant a lot. I feel like I was able to attend my own funeral. Aw. I know what you mean. Yeah, I just wanna say this.
I highly recommend to anybody out there who's working, get fired, have a going away party, have all your coworkers cry, get a severance package, go to Europe for a couple weeks, and just when you're thinking about how you're gonna be able to pay rent, go back to work. It's the ideal, the ideal career path, and I just wanna say thanks to everyone.
Awe. Well, I am just so excited about this new chapter. A big thank you to Odyssey for being our new partner. Yes. We are thrilled. We are so happy, about this new chapter. A big thank you to Odyssey for being our new partner. Yes! We are thrilled. We are so happy and we hope you guys have a great week. We are gonna see you next week and I think we got to hear Nora and the cast singing Sons and Daughters. I like that idea. We'll build our walls, aluminum. We'll fill our mouths, to sing about when we are right. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins, our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.